in saying we think there's four issues
we need to work on and make
recommendations to the
Judiciary the Judiciary having listened
in carefully either in person or by Zoom
or both um has already started to
implement some of these um which means
for a bunch of non- lawyers we didn't
get it too bad up here and we now have
two final subcommittee reports that we
will hear you should have copies of of
them and we'll talk about them and I
hope uh approve them and then there's
one final agenda item after that so the
subcommittee on Guardian
limp parenting coordinator
role uh the chair of that is
representative katab would you uh
present your subcommittee's report
please sure do you want me to read the
report or just go over highlight I'd say
go over the highlights okay so this
subcommittee was formed to look into
Guardian at lims and also parenting
coordinators and we ended up mostly
focusing on the parenting coordinator
model and house belill 1263 was passed
through the house it's now in Senate
Judiciary it got introduced last
Thursday so it hasn't been voted on
there
yet we felt like the parenting
coordinator might offer a little bit of
a
kind of a way of looking at a way of
dealing with this issue for now and
we've asked in the meantime when it's a
budget year if the court could collect
some data on G's which they were amable
to doing um mostly
just collecting on you know when a g
would have been used but perhaps
couldn't have couldn't have been
afforded and similarly if the if the
parenting coordinator is passed we'd
also like to know how often it's used
and then how often parties end up
agreeing on something just to kind of
have a few data points so I believe the
court has two judges that hear many of
these cases and they were going to those
two judges are going to kind of track
when they would have used a jail just to
kind of because there's no really not a
great way of tracking that piece but I
believe it's two is that right two three
okay three judges so that will be
tracked because that's kind of something
that
really needs to be looked at in a budget
year not in a not in a non-budget year
so that was where we left off there was
we ended up with the hb1 1263 and we
own happy to answer any questions if
anybody on the committee had
any attorney krian you want to respond
to this uh give us a little update from
please good morning Erin crean general
counsel for the judicial branch um I I
think I have to start by thanking the
committee so much for their interest in
this topic and and How Deeply immersed
you got into the work of the Family
Division I think you saw yourself
personally many cases where litigants
would have benefited from or appreciated
uh the assistance of either Guardians at
Lia or or other models um it is a little
difficult to track how consistently
we're we're not able to make
appointments and so we're going to work
on that anecdotal sample which will
hopefully be helpful uh to you with our
our very um large marital docket judges
tracking it and it will out of the total
number of cases they look at that may
give you an idea of how common it is uh
I personally did a fair amount of
research looking through old budget
codes with LBA trying to find out how
much this was funded at the past it
appears the code was reused uh for
another fund uh so the amounts that I
saw in some of the old budgets they they
they're clearly the the modern version
of that fund and not the historical
potentially larger than the actual past
expenditures were too bad this is being
recorded
huh well I I I want to be transparent I
know how frustrating it is that we we
haven't been able to find this number I
went and had a big stack of paper files
from one of our long time judges that I
was kind of rooting through thinking for
sure he had printed it out at one point
um but I I I don't think we're able to
figure out exactly how much the fund was
before it's certainly in the hundreds of
thousands um so hopefully this anecdotal
sample will be helpful to you and just
appreciate so much the committee's
area any questions for attorney
krian okay good seeing none thank you
um could I have a motion to accept this
report into our final report I saw move
okay
seconded moved and seconded to received
the subcommittee on Guardian at limp
parenting coordinator role into the
committee and uh
call you've got you can put on the face
of that who moved and who seconded
representative Smith moved and I think
representative ball seconded I seconded
okay and when you're ready uh please
role chairman Pearson
yes Vice chairman Smith
yes B
Greg rep ball
yes rep kab votes yes rep long yes R
McMahon
yes okay motion passes uh 7
to0 7 to zero it is now in the final
[Applause]
report next up draft report from the
subcomm
for consideration of the full membership
of the special committee on family court
on judicial training education
supervision
accountability and um Vice chair Smith
this is your
group thank you Mr chairman uh the
subcommittee um included uh
Representatives cab lonza Pearson and
myself when we last met I uh did submit
um the draft up until then um of the uh
of this subcommittee and I will not uh
go through all of that now because it's
already in the record but I'd like to
bring it up to date um and I'm going to
start um after um the text of the draft
includes the Supreme Court rule
45 continuing judicial education and
what follows is
this um the thought that it would be
timely for judges to receive essential
training within two years of appointment
as specified in the Supreme Court rules
demonstrates to the committee that the
Supreme Court does not take seriously
the need for training before the judge
is assigned
cases uh the committee understands that
the courts do not play a role in um in
appointing the
judges uh they can not specify
requirements in terms of experience in
lower courts or in particular subject
matter
jurisdictions but once the appointment
has been made by the governor and uh
confirmed by the executive Council then
everything else is in the Court's
hands um in conversations with court
Personnel the subcommittee did develop a
better understanding of the complexities
of developing an inclusive and effective
training program for the Circuit Court
there are 34 Court locations with wide
responsibilities including civil
criminal landlord family and probate
there currently is in place a six week
basic training that involves initial
orientation ethics Mental Health Ada
access and similar issues they're two
weeks of family core training that's
onethird of the total training time
including parenting guardianship
domestic violence and stalking there is
also limited opportunity to observe
experienced
judges unlike um the superior and
Supreme
Court Circuit Court judges have no
clerks and the entire court
shares as we understand at three staff
attorneys the subcommittee did develop a
whole series of questions um on uh what
is reasonable to expect
um for a
system
uh uh to be initiated uh which judges
should be required what about the
absence of support staff how do you
include in their decisions and
explanation of why they reach their
decision would requiring mediation
effectively reduce case loads and
therefore the time that any Cas is in
the system what specific staff should be
added to the court with responsibilities
to best manage inhouse and an external
training um and then there's some other
factors also about having um a big
brother or big sister in effect an
experienced judge paired with a judge
with no
experience um is it possible to have a
regular uh schedule of
supervision um
and might there be cases that could best
be handled outside the judicial system
for in order to a better meet the needs
of the citizens and more
completely
um uh again find a way to lessen to some
degree the case load that makes it
almost impossible for for
thoughtful uh judges to have as much
time as they need to make an informed
decision as we sit here today on April
2nd um House Bill
10:05 um which has to do with Education
and Training of Judges has passed the
house and is in um the finance committee
by the end of the day today it is highly
possible that that bill will have passed
out of the finance committee at the
moment it has been combined with two
other bills one of them being um the uh
uh a bale Reform Bill um uh and those of
us sitting here would prefer that the
bill be floating its own vote but that's
not the way finance committee sees it at
the moment the bill does however despite
a good deal of push back from some
principles involved the bill does
provide the specific number of hours for
training for judges and staff and for
the staff to plan and execute specific
training
requirements um it also has uh protected
the word shall rather than May um in
order to help
um
reinforce what I'm sure is the Court's
commitment to good training but what I
know is the legislator's commitment to
appropriate
training this legislation House Bill 105
which will end up with a different
number by the time it works its way
through would help help make it possible
for the courts to better carry out what
the legislature considers to be
essential in order for the Circuit Court
created by the legislature to best meet
the needs of New Hampshire
citizens thank you Mr chair thank you
for thank you for such a thorough report
chair would you like to come up attorney
krian
and
interact thank you Mr chairman again
Erin krian general counsel of the
judicial branch um one of the things
that I have observed in the work of the
committee and I and I haven't even been
in my position for all of it um is that
the courts continue in the way that
things are done and there are some very
very good ideas um that point out things
that now that I reflect on them
sometimes appear obvious uh
representative Smith's suggestion of
having more staff attorneys in the
circuit court is an excellent suggestion
uh that is a uh the life of a circuit
court judge is a harried existence with
very um little of the support that one
typically thinks of when one imagines a
judge um I often think of them as
firefighters uh they just go and work
and work and sometimes I talk to them
and they tell me that they have had
stress dreams about how many orders they
need to get out and and ensuring that
people do get timely Justice uh so I
know that this is um that that's a very
thoughtful and good suggestion it's it's
appeared in some of my fiscal notes now
uh where I say well maybe we could do
more with a staff attorney here as
opposed to uh requesting a full new
judge um and I know that many people in
this committee have been supportive of
uh having more judges as well um and
have had other really great ideas about
Staffing and and doing things
differently uh and the Circuit Court uh
represent ball I think of your
suggestion of working with the
Department of Education which was
excellent um it was it was intuitive it
it was just not something that we knew
to even ask or pursue and and we are
getting enrolled in that program now so
that we can have more people coming from
high school to work in the courts uh so
some of these suggestions have just well
all of the suggestions are are
appreciated but some of them are things
we wouldn't think of ourselves they're
they're more creative looking at other
states um imagining different ways that
things could be done knowing how other
parts of the government work from the
different other committees that you're
on or from your own past Public Service
in other areas um so it's it's something
that um I've really appreciated and uh I
think that that suggestion here is I
almost feel a little bit silly for not
having thought of it because when you
say it it makes so much sense um but
it's we we are used to persisting
sometimes in in the way that things have
been
done um
I I I I do appreciate I just want to
comment very briefly on um the issue
that um that you mentioned rip Smith
which is
I when I took this uh position I read a
few hundred pages of the uh relationship
between the legislature and the judicial
branch in the state of New Hampshire uh
which is a a very interesting history
and I I complimented uh representative
Lyn I told him that he was throughout
that history i' had seen his influence
in in Bar review articles and cases that
he determined um and I would not want
the judicial Branch's position on the
training issue to be taken as anything
that impedes their respect that the
judicial branch has for a recommendation
or for an observation that comes from
the legislature um you know that respect
exists in a in a hearing in a verbal
communication of a suggestion in a bill
um in in any form that it's received um
I know that there is great comedy
between the branches of government in
New Hampshire my most recent Billet was
working for the US Senate Judiciary
Committee the relationship between the
US Senate Judiciary Committee and the US
Federal Judiciary is not uh not this
collegial uh not characterized by this
level of of Comedy uh and close work
together uh I don't say that to be to be
negative on anyone there it's just
there's no history like the history that
there is here for the collaboration
between branches um so although that
remains the position it is not in any
way a uh a challenge to the power of the
legislature which is vast um the
legislature can destroy courts establish
new judgeships lower the maximum penalty
for murder to a year establish new civil
actions amongst many other things um the
power of the legislature um over the
court system is almost unlimited it has
simply been our position that there is a
very small Zone which is typically the
inner administrative work of the
Judiciary that is um the independence of
the Judiciary that training does come
within in the same way that discipline
came within in in R Petition of JCC um
when it the Supreme Court adjudicated it
a couple decades ago uh so I I I know
that this is a disagreement and it's and
it's a respectful disagreement um and I
would I hope that disagreement is is
taken in the spirit of great respect for
the role of the legislature to make
policy determinations great respect for
the work that you put into them and how
good these suggestions are and how much
they're
appreciated um but a difference of
opinion on a constitutional
matter before the committee had its
special committee had its first meeting
I spent some time with administrative
judge king and supreme Chief McDonald
and it was like a first
date and where you're trying not to make
a fool of yourself and try to make a
good impression and you're inching
hopefully realistically closer to each
other and what we all discovered is we
wanted to gang up against problems not
each other irrespective of what previous
iterations of special committee on the
courts may or may not have done and it
was that tone that continued and uh so
thank you for that
commentary um in terms of outside eyes
and your um embarrassment at not seeing
something I bring in occasionally
patients from the medical practice I'm
part-time CEO of
because the people who work for me are
so on top of what they're doing they see
that better than anyone and they also
miss things that people from a distance
can see so I intentionally bring in
certain patients that I know to be
articulate and savvy
and say please give a critique and I I
interrupt them after 4 minutes of lavish
praise saying thank you very much
appreciate that now how can we fix some
things gang up with us and they're
helpful and it's not because my staff
isn't capable it's they're in a silo and
the other people have outside eyes and
that's all to the
good
um if the question on any particular
issue issue where we apparently think
you should do something and you're
having some hesitancy if it is a
question of time or money or staff those
are issues that can be worked on
together as the next budget's put
together um also I am wondering uh about
the initial training if it should be
different if a new judge was previously
let me use the British terms a solicitor
rather than a barrister if you've got
newly appointed judges who don't try
cases in court but are real estate
attorneys and don't go to court but do
wonderful work might the training to be
a judge be longer and more intensive
than the training for a lawyer who has
been in court regularly or what if in a
different field I have a friend in
another state who is observing the Court
Circuit Court for similar reasons who
tells me how a wonderful lawyer was just
appointed to family court and for 20
years he was very distinguished as a
patent attorney and I offer that I
probably know more about Family Court
than he does so mightn't the initial
training be
um more structured around different
needs of incoming judges uh just a
thought I think that's a that's a very
apt observation and it does it does need
to be um changed depending on who is
coming in a a former marital Master is
very knowledgeable a a former prosecutor
is going to be great in District
division but is going to need more work
um for the Family Division um so that
that is something that we do try to do
because we have been onboarding sort of
one two three at a time it uh it has
been a little bit easier to specifically
structure the training to the the needs
of the individuals that are on boarding
I think we have three that we just went
through um a Long training period with
and we were able to be a little bit
different because their backgrounds were
a little bit different and so the fact
that we're usually not taking on a large
number all at one time has made that
that there are exceptions to that but at
least at this moment they're sort of
coming in um 1 two three at a time we
get a little bit more of an opportunity
to really here are training to the
particular individuals that are coming
on board take good notes because our
hope is this will continue the next two
budget
Cycles uh Vice chair Smith I think you
wanted to make some
comments I did want to thank you very
much for your comments and how
carefully attentive you were in terms of
how you you raised the issues that are
of some concern um
uh I I do want to comment on
one side comment that you made having to
do with your experience in
Washington and I would suggest you you
that over the
2 50 years or so there have been many
many times including recent times where
the legislative Branch uh both the the
house and the Senate um had very
positive relationships with the
Department of Justice and with the
courts and um it is
only sometimes in the history of this
country that there has been
um
where where each of the branches lost
sight of their common
purposes and um I want to make sure that
in New Hampshire we don't lose sight of
our common purposes without regard to
the
personalities of who at any specific
time is operating
any in any specific position so I thank
you very much for the care in which you
comments anyone else with a question or
a comment uh representative
McMahon thank you Mr
chair Atty krian to get your guidance uh
relative to the current status and what
is projected in the future uh based on
the report we have with Court rule 45
saying 2 years for additional
training are you in support of the bill
that's in finance right now stating that
the training would be completed within
three months of
hire um representative cutab was kind
enough to share the bill draft with me
before introduction and I did not
recommend any changes to her proposed
timelines which I know she researched I
believe she she reviewed other states
practices as well um so I I do not this
is a recommendation from the legislature
to the branch and we we receive it with
respect but we certainly have the
ability to implement that
um so it is it is not an inability to
implement the legislature's
recommendations in those areas the the
major issues that we had that are recent
relate to sort some sort of unusual
events including covid um where actually
we got a little bit of an opportunity to
do more training because some of the
cases were um not able to be heard it
wasn't it wasn't safe for folks to come
in right away uh so we sometimes might
take an opportunity like that and go
very very heavy in one year and you
might say the next year it doesn't need
to be quite as much because we utilize
that past opportunity so there are
certainly things that that happen that
adjust um what you might project in an
average year in an average onboarding
period but you know barring unusual
events we do try to train people within
that time period and we have um three
Circuit Court judges going through that
training I think they just completed
most of it um relatively quickly after
their um confirmation so I I think
that's something that we can Implement
and I um had the opportunity to consult
on that bill and did not um try to
adjust the time periods that she
recommended one followup Mr chair
followup U then relative to the bill
that you you have current currently
support on but notwithstanding any
adjustments to it is the three-month
timeline enough to complete the total
curriculum that's referenced in the
build in finance right now it is a
continuing curriculum um so it is it is
ongoing there's a continu education
requirement in addition to the initial
um it is not difficult to persuade
judges to engage in training um these
are people who voluntarily went to
school for 20 years and would probably
go back if they could um so the interest
is is there Judes love to do training I
know that there has been a little case
load stress um and I think also the
suggestion to have a Judicial training
coordinator is a good one I previously
um worked in a department that had a
dedicated Workforce uh training director
and the training that she was able to
procure and the work that she was able
to do persuading people to design new
trainings uh pers persuading people to
do free trainings going to experts and
and getting them to volunteer was
excellent it was the highest quality um
so I I do think that that suggestion is
a very good one that will lead to higher
quality training um but but we do have
the ability to implement those
continuing education requirements and
the initial training requirements one
last
followup and specific to the
uh rep report that we have before
us was stating the Circuit Court judges
do not have clerks is that some is that
not something we should be addressing as
a legislature to reduce the workload
that would then would allow this type of
uh continuing training to be
facilitated that's a that's a great
question and a great observation uh I do
think that that has the potential to be
a force multiplier for our judges um
that being said there are of course many
demands at all times on the the the
resources of the state and we want to be
mindful that we don't balance those
competing concerns the legislature does
they decide where the where the money
will go for new hires and and things of
that nature um but would we use that
would that make judges more effective
would it potentially mean that someone
who is not whose time is not as
expensive as a Judicial officer is able
to displace some of the work that's
currently being done by a Judicial
officer I think ultimately there would
probably be some savings there and and
potentially we would not be as
restricted as we are um in the
constitutionally which we have to be and
how judges are chosen they have to go
through a process but um if we needed to
we could hire more um it's not the same
lifetime commitment that that choosing a
Judicial officer is that has to be done
more carefully and only based on what we
know our needs will be for a long long
time um so I think that that's a very
sharp observation and something that
would make judges more effective thank
you Attorney K thank you Mr chair along
that line um in the medical part of The
Healing Center that I look after we have
doctors nurse practitioners and medical
assistants there was a week with a
Ultimate Storm of things coming together
where we had no nurse practitioners and
no medical assistants doctors were
putting patients into the room doctors
were doing all the things and the work
slowed way down and I'm thinking law is
not much different in terms of who's
backstopping the ones on the bench and
if there are um clerks and uh attorneys
backing up the judges it can get a lot
more work done and with less expense
than just just naming more judges
although we need to do that too so yeah
this is to be encouraged this needs to
be in the next um plea at budget time I
think um having been told on several
occasions by more than one from the
Judiciary that as the reports
recommendations are
implemented and the Judiciary welcomes
our
involvement I wonder how is it that we
do connect with you on that we don't
wish to be presumptuous but we do wish
to take you up on that and if
something's being put together um for
example forms in the local Court um how
do we who with whom do we talk so we can
say here we are pick me I want to help
how do we do
that uh great question I I certainly
will endeavor to connect uh you know
reach out to me anytime if you're trying
to get a hold of someone in the judicial
branch so that I can connect you with
the right person um if
there's something more specific to your
question in terms of a particular
project
um please let me know but I definitely
try to be your single point of contact I
do sometimes disclaim that I put the
general in general counsel and I don't
uh know as much as some others in the
branch do on other topics and uh I want
to make sure that you speak to someone
who is more knowledgeable than myself on
on some of these things particularly if
they're very technical um but I will get
you connected with the right person so
all of us here here and anyone who is
not here but is still interested in
doing this we'll let them know that on a
topic of interest to us we interface
with you and then you may refer us to
the next person that next person having
heard from you expect a phone
call yes sir anyone else anything else
on this report don't go away because we
get one more item after this if there is
nothing f further on this report um
chair will entertain a motion to accept
this
subcommittee report into the general
report move representative long and
representative ball any further
discussion the motion is to accept this
report into the general report when
ready the clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson yes Vice chair
Smith yes
rep
Greg rep ball yes rep cab yes rep long
70 now the third and final topic we have
is the speaker asked if once this was
all put together and if you would be so
kind as to give me what we already have
and I'll take this and I'll do some
editing and rewriting and and so on and
then get back to you okay
um the speaker asked would we now
adjourn the
committee
and I thought what if something of a
real hot button nature comes up over the
summer and we are now the ones who think
why didn't we see that but here it is
well we've just adjourned too late 10
years from now there's another special
committee or Mr Speaker we keep this
open until end of October and perhaps
decide this is a topic we want to
address name a subcommittee to go to
work on then reconvene this and that
subcommittee report we discuss to see if
it'll be in the final report and he said
sure keep it open so we are open and
I've handed notes or sent email to
various ones uh asking what do you think
might be a worthy topic for our
consideration now there's a number of
topics that can be suggested that are
very good but I do not see they fall
within the perview of the special
committee but there may be some which do
and this is is from representative Erica
Leon my former Vice chair when I chaired
Health and Human Services she said I
have heard numerous complaints that
unless there are broken
bones assault on a child and domestic
addressed in reviewing the statutes
district court has jurisdiction to
arraign defendants charged with felony
offenses and the a preliminary
examination to determine whether the
probable cause exists to believe the
offense was committed and the defendant
committed the offense and if so to be
bound over to the superior court for
further proceedings this is she says in
RSA 490
DF colon
3-a and she adds I would like to
understand what currently happens when a
child is physically or sexually
assaulted if there are already specific
guidelines on how the reports are
handled at
DCF uh that would be helpful uh is there
a likely intersection between dcyf and
the courts on this uh what might the
special committee choose to do on this
topic and I'm not stipulating to any of
the facts I've quoted I've just read a
report and I want to throw this out to
any member of the uh special committee
and also to attorney
craigan
yes representative Kap I think it's
definitely something worth looking into
I
think on a similar note we had also
discuss potentially looking into
domestic violence but I think because
they become Hot
Topics it becomes a
quick point of contention where people
are like oh we're not let's not look
into that but I doesn't mean that it's
any less important to look into I think
we we have these issues going on and I
think it's important that we potentially
do take some time to look into them and
I wonder if it could be
a potentially like an intersection of
looking into both abuse but also the DV
issue as well like if it could kind of
be a combined issue to look into both of
them because I do think that that that
is something that we continually heard
issues on
and I I feel like for DV it was a
similar situation where
some judges were giving orders where
people felt like they shouldn't have
been given but then on the extreme side
there was also some orders being given
where or some orders not being given
where people were like hey this
absolutely should have be given I mean
think the Lindsay Smith's C case and so
it seems like um there may be a similar
issue with abuse
where it's not kind of properly being
addressed and I wonder if this might be
an issue that we could take a look at
kind of
together might it be something that
internally Judiciary might wish to take
a private look at uh not necessarily
disposing of what's before us but at
least beforehand because it may be the
case that as you examine how this has
been hand handle you may see there's a
few judges that go way overboard on
giving orders and a few judges that
don't seem to do anything else and if
that is the case that is continuing
education individually some things can
be and should be handled that way before
they're handled more publicly at least
that much uh just a suggestion an answer
is not
needed
what are completely different and conent
right so work when it comes to
deal only thatview outside of the
criminal it's taking a look at it to see
if somebody else may Pi up the ball as
long as that
job we're looking at
that otherwise we are going to happen
anything that
happens charge cannot be
you thank you Mr chairman um one thing I
will say on the work of the special
committee on DCF is that I understand at
least at this moment that they're going
to start I think with the investigative
process that dcyf follows and I think
they're inviting the chiefs of police
and some others um the court does have a
role in the investigative process it is
a little more limited um you know by
statute on a probable cause finding we
can issue orders that for example allow
an interview of a child um so there
there are laws that the legislature has
passed that involve the court in some of
those early steps
um a very good kind of compendium of the
Court's role in abuse and neglect cases
is our our protocols um which are
available online and I'm happy to send a
a link to the researcher as well um that
just lays out the existing law that we
follow in investigative process and
different types of cases um certainly
the legislature can can make adjustments
in these areas but um I think the
investigative we have a little bit lower
of a role and I think that may be where
the committee is starting and then
eventually they will go through
potentially at a later time the court uh
process as well with abuses neglect
cases representative Leon who gave me
that piece I just read is now the chair
of the special committee on
DCF and when the email was followed up
with a phone call it was uh on the order
of the handoff from our perspective
Family Court what more should we ask for
look at whatever before then it becomes
a a matter of superior court and
different rules and different judges and
so on I think that's what she was
looking for is where is that connection
from us to her and I think there's
there's some Connection in the um the
abuse and neglect protocols um between
work that's done in the on our side in
the court side and then work's done in
the dcyf side because they do have to
interact with us for permission in a
number of areas um and that's probably
the best guide for anyone that wants to
learn more about what we're currently
required to
do representative Vice chair Smith thank
you um I'm interested also in the
difference between um the Civil
component and the
criminal
component and um I
myself uh would speaking only for myself
would be fearful of anything that we
might do that
unintentionally
blurs the separation between civil and
criminal particularly in terms of
um considered I I'm I'm picking my words
carefully here but because it's
certainly I don't want to say who are
charged because then we're off into a
different game um and I'm not
sure that this is the
place to do that and while I completely
sympathize with representative Leo
wanting to um find another little perch
for some of the enormous resp
responsibilities she has I'm not sure
place I I could not comment on on that
ma'am
uh the legislature has set um a lot of
guidance to the courts already in terms
of how to pursue an abuse and neglect
case the legislature can certainly
adjust um those standards um there are
competing concerns there there are the
rights of children there are the rights
of parents um the primary focus in a
criminal case is on the rights of the
defendant um the the primary focus in a
civil case is on the burden to the
plaintiff um and vindicating their
rights these are different frames um and
not everything is always handled the
same way by different states but I think
you do generally find that Most states
in abuse and neglect case the the
primary consideration is the best
interest of the child and that's it it
may be that all 50 states are identical
in that standard I have to do more
research but I think you that is a a
standard if it is the rights of the
child for abuse and neglect are we
separating abuse and neglect versus
physical sexual harm as two different
spheres one is civil the other is
Criminal is that where the line
is the standards are different uh in an
abuse and neglect case the primary issue
is what will what will happen to the
child next where will they be if if you
look at a criminal case um if the very
high burden of of um of proof is not met
then you default back to the situation
which existed before the case was
initiated if a defendant is not
convicted then they move about their
life as normal uh in an abuse neglect
case I think that would leave a question
about what happens next with the child
as opposed to what the disposition of
the parent is uh so abuse neglect is
focused on what is
next and what is best for the child the
criminal Cas is um either a very high
standard is met in which case a
potentially a very severe sanction is
imposed or it's not in which case no
sanction is imposed and no change to the
status quo occurs um just to clarify my
previous question is that roughly the
dividing line between civil and Criminal
Court there are others for different
case types but I would say in this
context yes generally for the liberal
arts guy yeah thank you yes repres PE um
I just had a question thank you for
answering and being here appreciate your
time um one of the things that came
forward in the testimony um was that if
people were
found not guilty in a criminal
court the concern was that then when it
came back to the family court where you
said that if they're found not guilty
they go on with their life but in
actuality they don't because then they
go back to Family Court who says well we
don't really care what Criminal Court
says because this is what we think so
we're still not going to get your
children and so you it's almost it's not
a double jeopardy but it's it's you're
still being penalized for something that
you were found not guilty of um so that
was the one that was the one case the
one person who came to testify and
that's what he was um saying so I I
appreciate that question and that does
happen that that the same set of facts
will be the subject of both a sim a
criminal and a civil case in which case
the fact that the cases have different
burdens um you know the very very high
Reasonable Doubt standard for criminal
and the lower preponderance of the
evidence clear and convincing evidence
standard for the civil case will result
that the very high burden of the
criminal case is not met but the the
still greater than 50% but not
reasonable Dow standard is met in the
civil case um so that that does happen I
think uh it's not uncommon for example
that a victim is not Vindicated in a
criminal case and then they sue the
defendant and they do obtain a result in
a civil case because the burden is lower
um so so that is not an unusual result
um Double Jeopardy explicitly bars a
criminal sanction imposed by the same
Sovereign uh right and I I I I
understand that but it almost is even
though you're going to a different
you're going to get the same result of
losing your children and I'm not saying
I'm on either side of that I'm just
asking I appreciate you explaining that
um just to clarify that that can happen
ma'am it can be that someone is not
convicted in a criminal case and yet
they do face a a civil they have the
same penalty regardless it should not be
the same it should not be typically a
civil sanction is not intended to be
punitive uh it's intended to vindicate
the rights of the the plaintiff or the
focus of the case so the plaintiff has
lost money in a civil case and they sue
to regain that money it can be punitive
if it's determined to be by Statute for
example punitive damages can be in a
civil statute but uh it's typically to
vindicate the rights of another person
as opposed to to um incapacitate or
retribute against a criminal defendant
just for a quick follow up so just for a
clarification so again we're going back
to that it's not supposed to be punitive
and and all that but take denying the
the parent their child is punitive so
that's where I think we're having this
real big that gray area that's where the
struggle is I think in the family court
and amongst the people who came to
testify as to how do we Rectify that
situation um and I think that's the real
the real sticky part of this whole um
thing and it it may well require that we
do more investigation into that area to
find out how do we how do we move
forward to make sure that someone
um
isn't um denied their children
unjustly that's a very tough balance a
lot of these laws you're looking at
different parties and their interests
and how you balance um their rights and
it's it's a very uh difficult job and
not every state has done it the exact
same way um they are a little different
from state to state um
it's it's certainly a challenging
question I think you do often see that
sometimes the state will try an approach
move back to a previous approach um
because it's so difficult to get that
that balance exactly right and I I don't
envy the the task that you have thank
you very much we've got just a few
minutes left in case there's anything
additional representative ball for
something additional thank you chairman
Pearson um so the only thing would bring
up is another thing that we might want
to talk about if we were to reconvene is
after the bills go through that we have
kind of um sponsored to get forward um
if they do not pass and they are not
signed by the governor that we may want
to come back and look at why these bills
may not have um gone forward and what we
can do to kind of go back to square one
and and see if there are any changes we
make
if anyone on the special committee
has further ideas please send them to me
in an email and if you want to flesh
them out with some commentary and even
make suggestions as to who might be
interested in this subcommittee uh in
this Committee in serving on a
subcommittee please do so and uh we've
got some time to do it excellent
excellent suggestion representative
ball with
that I adjourn the meeting of the
special committee and uh see you
sometime and thank you so much again for
coming Mr chair and speaking I'm sure
from my colleagues I would like to thank
you for your leadership on on this
committee which was not easy and um I
think we've made some progress all B
baby steps but have made some progress
so thank
you a leader is often as good as the
people whom he or she works with and
thank you for being an excellent
committee all right we will call up
anybody on the children and family law
committee who's out there in the gallery
and we'll uh take about a 3 or 4 minute
then
for
e
open the hearing on Senate Bill
566 relative to establishing a committee
to stutter foster care families and the
foster care system Prime sponsor Senator
chandley and look at that she knows the
first rule of testifying before this
committee turn the mic on thank you
thank you very much and good morning Mr
chair members of the committee um my
name is Shannon chandley and I serve the
people of marac Wilton Milford and
Amherst in District 11 in the Senate um
I come before you today to introduce
Senate Bill
566 as the chair said it is to establish
a committee to study foster care
families and the foster care system so
um I have served several terms in the
house and I'm in my second term in the
Senate and and throughout um my tenure I
have received calls from constituents
who have concerns about the foster care
system um you know these concerns um
sometimes people are quite desperate I'm
sure you've heard some of the um the
concerns that the folks have raised to
me here in your committee um they are
include they include um uh uh certainly
a lack of uh placements for foster
children um discrepancies between kin
and non-kin fostering uh requirements of
the Foster family and the living space
so this bill was a way of trying to um
look at the entire issue in one setting
for a while I tried to come up with um
certain ways to maybe uh how can we and
for lack of the better term I'll use the
word fix the system but I think that
it's not necessarily A system that is
broken it is a system that needs to be
um looked at so problems identified
challenges identified and solutions
created and I think that a study
committee might be the best place to do
that um I've reached out to various
shareholder uh stakeholders advocates
and um members of the legislature who
are expert in this area and that
certainly includes um your chair and
honorable members of this committee and
I widespread support for doing this I
considered that there are there have
been um foster care subcommittees in the
uh oversight committee on
DHHS and there are other committees that
commissions and committees that look at
Children's Services but in con in um
consultation with a number of people
with expertise in the area seemed like
this might be the best way to move
forward um the bill is very simple it
sets up your standard uh study committee
and I know many of us are loathed to uh
put forward more study committees where
issues are extremely important we need
to do that and um the charge is uh to
assess the regulations and requirements
to qualify as a foster parent um um the
special circumstances of foster care
provided by relatives and how to best
provide guidance to recruit and CA uh
and maintain um potential Foster
families um it's not limited to that and
the the committee as it does its work
May find other areas where there are
issues and identify those as um needing
Solutions so with that I ask you to look
favorably upon sb56 6 and um happy to
take any questions if you have any thank
you before I turn them loose I'm just
noticing the allstar cast of House
members you have as
co-sponsors Greg Pearson patrino sidal
wow it is it is I said that I could I
reached out to folks with a real if not
expertise working knowledge of these
issues and certainly the members of this
committee are those folks as my father
often said don't your shoulder out by
excessively patting yourself on the back
any questions for the
senator representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question fabulous Bill
I just have one quick question
um on line8 it says the members of the
committee shall receive mileage at the
legislative rate is there a reason to
not include federal rate I'm just
thinking of the accounting nightmare for
the
that's the
same it is not no it's not so if that is
something that needs to be addressed
absolutely not a problem to address it
for the uh for the members of the
committee who would be eligible for that
rate I think it's worth
um does anyone know the difference so
I I know there is the state rate and the
federal rate but I did not I I assume
both were um encompassed in legislative
rate but that I I am absolutely willing
to change that to accommodate the
federal rate is not um included in your
income tax on your
1040 we can elect as I
recall the federal rate or or the
legislative rate legislative rate
becomes income I signed off saying I
wanted the federal rate and that is how
I've been paid for8 years
and that's that's the reason I ask I
can't imagine
that this person gets the federal rate
for the rest of their legislative rates
while we have the senator here um
perhaps we could move past our own
wallets and ask her any questions about
welcome representative Raymond thank you
Mr uh chairman and thank you for taking
my question sure so this is only my
first term in the house and so I don't
have uh a huge familiarity with study
committees so when a committee like this
is formed do you also investigate how
other states potentially are doing
foster care and if there's things that
we can learn from them or is it only
kind of a review of our internal systems
it would Encompass both because it
really is at the um the chair will the
committee will be established and the
chair is able to run the committee as um
the chair sees fit and I think that
given C certainly within the parameters
outlined in the bill the uh chair may
decide that the way to do this is to
call in some of um the people from the
state and from the other agencies with
whom the state contracts to understand
what the situation is the there may also
be um people who have some concerns or
complaints who want to come and address
uh raise those issues before the
committee and in terms of seeking
Solutions looking at other states is one
of the potential ways to find
Solutions do you have a candidate from
the senate in mind who might like to
chair this committee um there are
several able and willing folks and um I
would certainly um be happy to do so but
I'm I'm defer to um the Senate
president's appointment you have good
Senators on this too okay anyone
else representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman Senator chandley uh just wanted
to ask uh in um for preface my question
is in optimizing the performance level
of the committee to be
appointed the starting point being has
there been an audit done of the foster
care system in in the state of New
Hampshire you know I would think that
would something be something that would
have to be looked into I don't know how
recently that has been done one follow
up Mr chairman follow up and then uh
because the with with the goal of
getting this done while we're young
because this is a very important issue
uh would would you be aware though of
any highlights of um subject matters
that would be prevalent as issue one and
two for the committee to address so I
think issue one is pro and of course
again this is subjective but issue one
may well be um how do we make sure that
we have enough foster care parents
available and issue number two is what
do we do to train and um and guide them
in their role as foster parents um and
and I guess I'll I'll make that issue
number one those two things are issue
number one and issue number two would be
what are the barriers why do people not
serve or why do they back away from
serving so a fiscal no would be a
reality in in this
work a any any solutions that would be
proposed through legislation would
likely have a fiscal note but I'm not
sure of that thank you Senator welcome
chairman what do you think
folks
thumbs thumbs are unofficial votes
oh you uh are not in Massachusetts
anymore representative only one thumb
please thank you thank you who'd like to
move OTP on this make a motion to OTP
okay OTP by representative patrino and I
love to do bipartisan who what uh
representative
Nelson I I second but I do have a
question though because would we have to
you may have a question it's been moved
in second so we may have questions thank
you Mr chairman um thank you um to
representative D Simon for um catching
that would we have to put through an
amendment to get rid of that U
legislative
or this could be done by a floor
amendment that would be mutually wiped
off
um excuse me could you uh call the rooll
and I'll speak and then I got to take a
phone call okay we're going to call the
okay shair votes yes all
right the chairman votes
yay representative long yes
representative disimon yes
representative
bfid representative bfit is not present
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Melvin is not
present representative uh
Gman yes representative LC yes
representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons is not present
representative Raymond yes motion
carries 13 to0 13 to Z three not present
who would like to write the committee
report yeah yeah we'll do thank
much um repr Senator before you leave um
uh just we can be in touch often the
speaker asks me for recommendations to
committees for him to make the
appointment and if there is a particular
House member that in your work you have
identified as singularly qualified on
this I'd be interested in knowing that
okay and members of the committee I've
already got someone pass me a note
interested so if there's others just let
you now open the hearing on Senate Bill
with uh
Senator bossy uh Senator Ward
sorry in for Senator Ward is Mr Grant FY
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh Senator Ward
is a bit under the weather this morning
she asked me to pinch hit we appreciate
the courtesy uh my name is Grant bossi
I'm the Deputy Chief of Staff in the New
Hampshire Senate here to introduce
Senate Bill 572 for Senator Ward the
prime sponsor
uh Mr chairman the list of house
co-sponsors on this bill is not as long
as the last bill you heard but it is
quality uh the office of child advocate
brought this
is the office of child advocate brought
this issue to Senator Ward uh in the
fall after conducting an in-depth
investigation into incidents of severe
child abuse where a number of infants
were not adequately protected in the
welfare system due in part to the
inability of DCF medical providers and
law enforcement to timely and
effectively share
information uh that's why she introduced
Senate Bill 572 a bill that establishes
a commission to study the sharing of
confidential records between law
enforcement the medical community child
protection services and the legal
Community this problem implicates a
number of state and federal statutes as
well as policies and procedures across
these three sectors the commission will
study the relevant laws the barriers to
information sharing in this Arena of
multi-disciplinary teams to investigate
child abuse and how to prevent such
roadblocks since many agencies are
involved in the work uh we need to
safeguard the sharing of information so
our children are protected while their
privacy is also protected I want to
thank you Senator Ward thanks you for
your consideration and support of Senate
Bill 572 I would defer questions to some
of the Advocates we have here and if
there's anything they can't answer I can
get your questions to Senator Ward and
Bickford thank you Mr chairman thank you
for take my question um so what we've
got is a few U entities that can't share
information with each other right like
hipper is a a problem for you right yeah
there there are privacy conc concerns
with both medical and law enforcement
they have their own standards and
getting through those silos so people
can know when children are at risk is
the challenge and hipper is a federal
law isn't it it is and so now what about
the law enforcement one uh well there
are various uh privacy concerns when
you're dealing with a an
investigation so state and federal laws
this is what the commission would would
do is look at all the relevant laws that
you need to comply with to see how how
can how can we share information without
breaking either state or federal law the
multidisiplinary followup yeah thank you
uh Mr chairman the multidisciplinary uh
thing is about uh professional people uh
getting together that are involved in
the child's issues right correct um and
they they've been doing that for some
years now and so how have they worked
in the past without this with the
problem of this federal law and uh and
police now police
are um can't share like
Juvenile Justice things criminal okay
and is there something else
about police can't share well that
getting in any specific cases that have
happened in the past Senator Ward saw
specific instances where children were
at risk and the right people weren't
able to tell the other people uh what
they knew so that they might be able to
prevent a tragedy this is what the the
purpose of the commission would be is to
find out where there might be gaps in
the
system is your follow up is are there
any other entities besides those two
entities that have a a non-communication
issue well I think you'll see if you
look at the text of the bill there are a
number of stakeholders that are included
and I think uh you've got the courts
you've got the office of child advocate
DCF um the house and the Senate and um
law enforcement Hospital friction points
I'm looking for the yeah I I think
that's something the commission would be
involved in in fleshing out and and
finding I I couldn't tell myself the
only two okay yeah thank
you anything
further seeing nothing thank you so much
thank you and if the senator could uh be
in touch with me uh a little bit later
on when the names of the committee will
be put together I appreciate that thank
you thank you chair recognizes um I
think I get it right Amy Roy or
that's oh there we go okay good
morning uh my name is Dr Amy Roy I am a
pediatric emergency medicine doctor uh
with the Elliott hospital and then I
of sorry um I also conduct specialized
medical exams for the child protection
programs both with the Elliot and at
Dartmouth um I've been in that role I
think for about seven or eight years now
and uh certainly have encountered over
that time lots of issues with sharing of
information um as these
multidisciplinary teams have sort of uh
taken root in New Hampshire you know I
think we in the medical community
certainly recognize them as really being
an invaluable tool for child protection
these provide uh a really critical and a
unique opportunity for um dialogue
between medical community child
protective services between law
enforcement sometimes other stakeholders
such as mental health and uh may serve
when we are able to come together and
have the kind of dialogue that we need
to have as an opportunity to really sort
of solidify and crystallize in uh in in
the sort of minds of those agencies that
there is significant reason for concern
for abuse and a real need to move
forward expeditiously um equally
importantly and I actually have a good
example of this uh sometimes what comes
out of these Medical out of these
multi-disciplinary team meetings is an
equally important opportunity to resolve
a concern for abuse so that a family may
really be able to put that episode
behind them and to um and to move
forward uh a recurring stumbling block
as we've already heard referenced here
is um the capacity to share information
and certainly amongst the medical
community um a pervasive concern is
Hippa fear of a HIPPA violation
and the difficulty that most routine
medical providers have in really
understanding the nuances of HIPPA which
is a big complex piece of federal
legislation and in knowing where there
are in fact protections and
opportunities to share information um
certainly it's hard to believe that the
intention of HIPPA is to prevent the
sharing of information that is really
gerine to um to Children's Health but we
uh certainly need help in understanding
how to communicate that what the sort of
guardrails are and how to function
effectively but also legally within that
multi-disciplinary team um setting I
think it's also important to remember
you know when we look at who is signing
consents to release information you know
in many of these instances a parent may
also be a perpetrator and that can be a
little bit complicated um so I think I
can say with real confidence that the
medical community would uh urge and
embrace the passing of this bill so that
we can have some clarity that would
allow us to um make these teams the
effective tool that we know that they
can
be and I'm happy to take any questions
if there are any any questions
representative Vice chair long thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for your
testimony uh the testimony that we get
here often is medical uh
because if you have medical information
at the school district for example
that's not their medical in
information um it's your medical
information uh now my understanding
medically is I don't know about four
years ago or
sooner um if the entity was
under
um uh if they if they were held to the
same uh confidential ity requirements
then it could be passed is is that still
the understanding I'm not sure I
understand that completely well it was
mostly on when we were looking at uh
doing um video uh medical appointments
but via vid video okay uh the passing
the passing we we looked at the passing
of
information um so that the other entity
wouldn't have to start from the
beginning um and we found out that if
they're beholden to
confidentiality then that information
can be passed to them are you familiar
with any changes of that sort no I feel
like I might not be the best person for
this question but I think you know
between when there's sharing information
between medical providers who are really
operating under that same framework then
yes that is allowed um and beyond that I
don't believe so but I may not the
person to ask okay all right thank you
any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
thank you J recognizes Lisa masio and
Jennifer Jones from the office of the
child
advocate
good morning everyone Lissa masio I am
the associate child advocate and with me
is Jennifer Jones one of our assistant
child Advocates I feel like I haven't
seen you all for a while you're we've
missed you too I've missed
you uh so we are here um as uh Senator
Ward's representative said uh this bill
was born of an issue that the office dis
discovered um last springish into the
fall um as you know we are an
independent oversight agency overseeing
All State serving
agencies um and we support this bill
obviously as we helped write it we
worked closely with Senators Carson and
Senator Whitley and the oversight
commission for children's services
around this issue um to increase
protection for vulnerable children and
this piece of uh legislation is kind of
central to that work in increasing
communication um around members of the
multidisciplinary team so I'm going to
let um Miss Jones here talk about the
process that this bill was born of a
little bit and the specific players to
answer some of the questions that have
been
asked good morning lovely to be here
with you all I feel like I haven't seen
this Committee in some time myself so
it's nice to be back um so I I want to
talk a bit
about kind of getting down to the
technical pieces of what a
multidisciplinary team does and um why
it's so important that a
multi-disciplinary team is able to
collaborate so when there is an
investigation concerning child abuse and
or neglect um particularly with
reference to the investigation that
office of the child advocate conducted
um as Lisa mentioned um last year um we
took to look at approximately nine cases
where there were serious bodily injury
to 11 non-ambulatory infants so when
you're looking at a case like that
there's always going to be law
enforcement in dcyf so your stage Child
Protection collaboration that's a co-
investigation because we're not only
looking at child safety but we're
looking at potential uh a criminal
aspect we know small infants can't
injure themselves um in the way that
they were injured in these cases that we
we had um been uh our office had been
referred to so as we took a deep dive
into the communication so there were two
aspects to it we took a deep dive into
reviewing the records for each of these
individual cases meaning we were looking
at the communication between all members
of the multi-disciplinary team so that
includes law enforcement Child
Protection uh
prosecution excuse me as Dr Roy
mentioned sometimes that includes other
entities um like your non- investigative
collaborative team members like uh
crisis centers mental health and so we
were looking at again the communication
between those uh entities and how they
were collaborating as an investigative
team and we also did a system mapping
review so that we could look at human
factors right things that were barriers
um or things that may have occurred or
happened um just in decision day-to-day
decision- making of those investigators
as well as system barriers so we largely
found that in almost all of those cases
there was a breakdown in communication
at some point in time um that could have
been in the onset where law enforcement
was responding and asking questions and
getting information without the presence
of DCF or um quite the opposite where
CPS was out responding in the immediate
and law enforcement hadn't been looped
in just yet and so those investigations
um there's a lot of moving parts so it's
not just about the child or infant being
seen in the immediate in the medical
information that may come out of that
one time appointment or that one time um
uh you know referral to the Ed or um you
know there's there's lab work there's um
follow-up skeletal surveys that may
uncover or identify additional injuries
that didn't exist at the time of the
first initial examination and so what
happens is um in the respective
investigations as that information
continues to present itself so as you
know you can imagine it takes some time
for lab work to get back it takes
approximately two weeks for a skeletal
survey to occur if the investigative
agencies are getting that
information at different times and not
able to share it creates a real
disadvantage about what one another
knows about their investigation and how
they're
collaborating um and so we found it
imperative um to have this um study
commission to really get get to some of
you know representative bigford had some
great questions um along with
representative long about like how does
that work how can you do that in a
legally defensible way and that's why we
want this study commission so what does
it look like when there's medical issues
right but they're specific to child
abuse and what and how do we pursue
those
investigations while honoring the
Privacy that all people are entitled to
medically but understanding that this
isn't you know this isn't just calling
up and inquiring about somebody's you
know average visit to their primary care
physician this is a child abuse
investigation and safety is Paramount so
what does that look like and how can we
navigate it in a way that um we're
really not running into um one
investigative agency having information
the other doesn't um as you can imagine
a collaborative investigation requires
good communication and timely
communication another um issue that we
were able to um elicit from our system
mapping is that this also um sort of in
the long game when these things go to
trial if dcyf and or law enforcement
don't have the Child's full medical
record and they don't have all the
records in their Discovery medical
professionals can't speak to it at trial
as expert Witnesses and that really
really can impede the judge's ability to
assess safety in a way that they have
all of the facts and so there's a lot of
it's a really multifaceted issue and
that's why we are fully in support of
the study commission um thank you so
much for your time I'm happy to answer
any questions oh sorry did you have more
all I you can either ask questions or I
can tell you more and then you can ask
both of us questions up to you
sir I'll I pick B okay I'll keep going
so um as Jen said it it is a very
complex area rather than us just try and
write a bill that would somehow cover
Hippa and law enforcement and dcyf the
study commission will help because some
of the specific barriers we were seeing
is it does appear under the current laws
and I I did attach you I know we all
like appendices appendix a which is a
compilation of all the relevant
rsas it is clear from those read
together that the legislature intends
for these multi disciplinary teams to be
able to communicate however
unfortunately there are some gaps some
of these statutes require rulemaking
which just never occurred so that's a
gap some of them just sort of become
circular in logic so for example DCF
gets medical records and they get law
enforcement records however they
currently read their confidentiality
statute to mean they can only disclose
their records I things they created
their case notes not even to include the
cap exam that they paid for and sent the
child too so there's this this like
chicken in the egg problem that DCF now
has a lot of records and can't share it
with anybody else they can't give law
enforcement the cap exam they can't tell
medical what's happening um so that's um
a gap that needs to be solved however we
didn't want to just sort of infringe a
solution on them we wanted the players
to come to the table and say how can we
overcome that similarly law enforcement
especially during an active
investigation against a parent of one of
these
children don't necessarily want to share
notes about an active investigation
because if they give it to dcyf because
this is a court case they're required to
disclose it in Discovery so now you're
actually giving records to the
perpetrator so it's it's a complicated
issue in that mapping all of the parties
said we really want to fix this we
really want to be able to talk to each
other but these are all complicated
issues we need to sit down at a table
and figure out what to do uh that
mapping did also discover another Gap um
at the court that some of the current
laws around abuse and neglect RSA 169
see the definitions are being
interpreted in a way to require a much
higher standard than necessary so we do
have another bill I believe you're
hearing soon uh when it comes over SB
459 addresses that issue so we're trying
to kind of address the discrete issues
and allow this multi-disciplinary team
which the legislature created but now
execution now you get to ask questions
that's Vice chairman long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
your testimony um I mean this is
probably going to put a stick in the
wheel uh but we hear several testimony
uh of parents being left out of the loop
I you know I I understand there are some
things you want to keep from them if
they are the ones being investigated but
we're off often hearing that even if the
court or somebody deems uh that it
wasn't at that level they're still not
hearing that and and um the child is
still either being kept from them or so
I'm wondering if
that's I mean I get this information um
confidential
sharing um but also if parents could be
even a parent that's not
um um that's not uh being investigated
for abuse uh they're not getting the
information um so they don't know what's
happening with their child they don't
know what one entity or another entity
whether it's law enforcement
DCF uh whomever um so I I I think that
would be I I think it would be helpful
knowing where the gaps are and with the
parents uh we know what we want to keep
from whomever is being investigated I
get that uh but my understand through um
testimony uh from parents is that
they're not getting investigated however
they still can't get any information
about their child so this Bill thank you
for the question and I hear what you're
saying because we've we've heard similar
things frankly parents call our office
saying I can't figure out what's going
on um this particular Bill send them to
you feel free um this particular bill
has to do with the professional
multidisciplinary team which is created
under statute already it is only
professionals sharing information about
an ongoing open child abuse case under
some of the statutes though that I
included in this appendix though RSA 170
g8a is dcf's confidentiality statute
which is very clear that a parent who is
under
investigation is allowed to get in
information about their case unless the
department determines that disclosing to
that parent likely if they are a
potential perpetrator would um the harm
to the child would be outweighed so
that's within the statute it's also
within um again sometimes there have
been administrative rules that should be
made that haven't been made or maybe are
outdated um but parents receiving
information I think would be a separate
issue that a parent would need to deal
with with these separate entities law
enforcement has rules around who's
allowed to see an ongoing investigation
which is usually nobody and then Hippa
as Dr Roy mentioned it is actually
usually the parent that holds all the
control in a hipa situation as far as
giving consent which again in this case
if the parent is the perpetrator
allowing them to refuse to disclose that
child's medical records can actually
really endanger that child um but
parents getting information is actually
part of some of these statutes and is
separate from this particular
multi-disciplinary team just because of
the way it was established in statute
you sing no more cards on this Bill
what oh I'm
sorry representative McMahon sorry no no
that's fine you're multi asking as
always Mr chairman don't worry about it
I just have a question for see it's
moving up I used to miss representative
Raymond and I got that one solved and
yeah
sorry Cooperative collaboration to
achieve consensus is now in place
okay attorney I relative to the 170 G8
confidentiality uh that you kindly
provided it uh I want to ask your
guidance on relative to the authority
having jurisdiction it appears to be the
commissioner or design on
whether
information it says here if it outweighs
the need for the disclosure then they
can um deny that would you have
recommendations on specific language
that would need to be changed in
existing law so it doesn't become a
Quantum physic calculation as to impact
but it is application versus
interpretation of application of
distribution of confidential information
thank you for your question I think this
study commission could potentially take
up that question as part of of the
multidisiplinary team I can tell you
from when I was a dcyf attorney um so
these aren't 91a requests so they're not
handled in quite the same way these 170
g8a information requests typically do go
to the legal department within any uh
district office and then the discussion
is held um at that level of weighing the
those pros and cons of danger to that
child for the disclosure versus the
parents right under the statute to get
the records it can go all the way up to
field administrator level or you know
dcyf State office level typically the
commissioner herself is not involved in
those conversations um but it certainly
could be um part of a conversation
around this statute I think this multi-
disciplinary team because the parent is
not part of that professional team That
explicit
question would not come up but this
statute's key as far as what information
sharing means who's assessing it and at
what level so um P perhaps language
could be offered um I
think I don't know of any personal cases
where this has been an issue right now
it it is meant to the whole statute is
meant to protect children so it is
weighed with the child safety in mind
one followup Mr chair follow up they
stipulate to agreeing with you on
protecting the children that's not up
for debate the issue is the application
of the protection for the children as
you both of correctly pointed out if the
commissioner is playing a major role in
this is there a representative I was
just looking at who's the members of the
committee is there a representative of
the commissioner's office that then
would then that should be if not so
designated a part of this uh
collaborative effort so the folks that
are on this particular study commission
are relating more specifically to that
multi-disciplinary team so it is the
director of dcyf who would sort of
represent the field and then the a
representative of the DCF legal
department because it is the dcyf legal
department that ultimately is making
these
interpretations of
statutory release so it is DCF legal
that has decided even though this is our
cap exam that we have done we can't show
it to anybody else because that's how
we're reading the statute so I think
probably especially because DHHS is such
a huge uh Department the commissioner's
office is not really a person that's
involved with this multi- disciplinary
team particularly but it is dcyf legal
as well as DCF director who's ultimately
kind of assessing those specific cases
okay I'll leave it at that thank thank
you attorney thank you Mr
chairman
after a Resolute search I see no hands
up so thank you so much thank you and
this uh concludes the hearing on Senate
Bill
572 Senator Ward and I had an extensive
conversation about a few aspects of this
bill so you are now being
handed an
yes this is hot off the press the
amendment has been worked and reworked
um and once you
uh can I have one please sorry may I
have one excuse
me so once you get it I suggest you put
it side by side with
um the original bill the bill is
submitted and I'll walk you through the
made and for the OCA purposes uh let me
give you a sneak peek uh for reasons
I'll elaborate everybody else on the
commission now becomes consultants and
the only members of the renamed
committee are five legislators this is
because of recently passed RSA
1449 but everybody who was not a
legislator who was in the commission is
also being mentioned by title as
consultants because we want them there
and then there's a few other adjustments
along the way so this is not substantive
to the task of this group it is simply a
matter of bringing the membership into
compliance with uh an RSA so if
everybody has um both please look at the
original
26 line 26 says notwithstanding RSA 1449
the membership of the commission shall
be in other words I know it's in law but
we're not going to do it that way um
we're backing off that um and so if you
look over at the amend Amendment page 1
line 11 the members of the committee and
it's named now a committee not a
commission shall be as before one member
of the Senate is appointed by the
president of the Senate Senator Ward
suggests four members of the House
appointed by the Speaker of the House of
Representatives one from this committee
one from Health and Human Services
elderly Affairs committee and two
members from any
committee we want to make sure we get
the subject matter expert s from the
house appointed as they will do in the
Senate at least one of whom shall be a
member of the minority party now look at
line 16 the committee shall te shall
seek testimony from various persons and
agencies in order to accomplish its
purpose these shall include but not
limited to that's the whole list of
people and the bill is submitted on the
top of page two it's the same folks we
want them there
but the reason the LSR was was made was
large committees with Quorum uh find
sometimes they don't make their Quorum
they have difficulties in steering a
large ship so we want them to come if
they want to come to every meeting
they're welcome to if they only can come
to certain meetings that doesn't
penalize the work of the committee so
that's the main change but continuing on
in the amendment
therefore uh page two in the
amendment
um the original bill says this group
will meet 10
times and then it said the preliminary
report will be November 1st good luck
and then it said the final report will
be in 2025 which is after the
election so there some we saw some
difficulties with that and so the 10
meetings is out they can meet as often
as the five of them are willing to meet
and the final report is due in
2024 so that is the amendment Senate
award and I came up with um which we
think makes this a more wieldy
committee
um so I'll give you a minute
to chew on that and ask any questions Mr
chairman may I yes um same question uh
page two line 21 of which bill the bill
or the amendment the amendment the
amendment page two
line1 um same question with with the
since the other Bill the mileage members
of the committee should receive mileage
at the legislative rate all I can say is
I've been serving on committees and
commissions for eight years now here and
that's the language I've always seen
and I've never failed to be paid well
okay thank you so we'll check that out
representative um just to get an
official answer on that thank you thank
you anyone else Vice chairman long uh
thank you Mr chairman so on line 21 the
uh 10 meetings of the original Bill no
this is on the amendment there is no 10
meetings in the
amendment line 21 no line 21 is a about
mileage you read that's a previous
Amendment Al this the amendment in play
is number
1397 I don't know that okay that went
passing by if anybody's got an
extra there were 20 some a of I I didn't
take it because I thought I had it okay
yeah we have an extra right here Mr
you so that's uh remove moved they can
meet 10 times it'll be up to
them any further questions on uh the
Amendments oh sorry yes representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman right past
representative McMahon yeah on um page
two line 25 it says the first meeting
shall be held within 45 days of the
effective date of this section is that
45 days from when the governor signs it
I feel like it it should be obvious and
then I started questioning it and was
like oh my well yeah you're in your
first term I figured that one out in my
second term so you're
ahead thank you sir that does not mean
informal but legal under 91a
conversations may not be held
individuals may not do research
individuals may talk with the people who
are coming to testify as experts just
official meeting has to be held within
45 days they can get to work now if they
want to quietly individually
individually okay yeah it's it feels
really tight thank
you well there's a lot of bills with
exactly this
else I am are we ready to go on this
thumbs this one's pretty easy too thumbs
just one from yeah thank you then I open
the executive session on Senate Bill 572
and I move Amendment
1397 is there a
second on second on the who's that
Raymond on the end yes oh I'm sorry I
didn't see Miss
Perez
oh all right sorry one second
representative
Perez now any further discussion on the
amendment you see why it was done the
senator signed off on this no Committee
of conference we're not worried about
rooll chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman
long yes representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes yes
representative panck yes representative
Melvin yes representative grman yes
representative L yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Raymond yes 15
absent and now the bill as amended I
move on to pass as Amendment amended
and uh representative
Greg any further discussion this speak
now the motion is ought to pass as
Amendment as amended by Amendment 1397
the bill is Senate Bill 572 moved by m
Pearson seconded by Greg would the clerk
please call the role jamond Pearson yes
Vice jamond long yes representative of
disimon yes representative bfid yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Melvin yes representative grman yes
representative LC yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Raymond yes motion
carries 15 to zero with one absent any
objection to
consent hearing
none this closes the exec session on
Senate Bill 572 and I am reopening the
exec session on Senate Bill 566 any
objection to consent that was Senator
chandy's Bill it passed 130 I have a
question Mr chairman yes can it be on
consent if it needs an amendment for
that legislative or are we just going to
leave it as it was with legislative
mileage I think we can get a floor
Amendment if necessary in which case
it'll be pulled off consent yeah oh okay
okay thank you for the
clarification I'll take a Voice vote on
consent on Senate Bill 566 all in favor
opposed thank you okay and that closes
566 now open the hearing on Senate Bill
359 raising the marriage age
to 18 and we have Senator iller to
do also an Allstar cast of House
co-sponsors namely long
Petrino and if you look down at the bill
and wonder why under committee it says
Judiciary and you didn't know this is
now the Judiciary Committee the fact
place
Mr chair are there copies I don't have
my actual copy of the bill just all my
supporting testimony shall I I don't
know um my assistant committee
researcher might know and if not there
you go thank
right and we'll just hold off one second
attention
okay I should have suggested after we
just looked at 572 if there's any uh
members of this committee that would be
interested in appointments uh I have a
ticket from one if there's any others
just send me a note or let me know um
when I make recommendations uh to the
speaker I think we're good senator
please thank you Mr chair and honorable
committee members my name is Deborah
alcher I represent Senate District 24
which includes the towns of exor
Greenland Hampton Hampton Falls
Northampton Ry and stratum I am honored
to bring Senate Bill 359 to you with the
Wind of unanimous Judiciary Committee
ought to pass recommendation and a
consent vote consent vote in sales this
proposal seeks to amend RSA
4574 and raise the age to enter into a
marriage contract to 18 years old as of
July 2023 10 states have banned underage
marriages with no exceptions requiring
marriage license applicants to be a
minimum of 18 years old Delaware and New
Jersey did it in 2018 Pennsylvania and
Minnesota in 201 20 Rhode Island and New
York in
2021 Massachusetts in
2022 and Connecticut Michigan and
Vermont in
2023 in New Hampshire the average age a
woman enters into marriage is
26.8 and for men it is 29.3 years old
nationally according to the US Census
Bureau the median age for marriage is
approximately 28 .6 years old for women
and 30.5 years old for men children
entering into marriage contracts is
wildly out of our current cultural norms
in the back of your pocket of your
packet are two graphs showing the change
in the entrance to the contract of
marriage for American men and women
between the ages of 2 between the years
of 2000 and
2023 New Hampshire allowed
215 child marriages nine of them since
the marriage age was just recently
raised to 16 child marriage is a tactic
used by child traffickers to control
victims the center for for Disease
Control and prevention conducts the
national survey of family growth which
gathers information on pregnancy and
births marriage and cohabitation
infertility the use of contraception
family life and general reproductive
Health the survey results are used by
the US Department of Health and Human
Services and others to plan health
services and health education programs
and to do statistical studies of
families fertility and
health according to the nsfg after 5
years of marriage couples who married as
teens have a 38% risk of divorce and
those who got married between the ages
of 20 and 24 at a 27% risk it drops down
to 10% if you wait until 30 to 34 to get
married 80% of child marriages end in
divorce there is no data to support
child marriage children entering into a
marriage contract is just not a path to
success Senate Bill F 359 empowers
granite State adults to enter into the
contract of marriage as legal adults
previous objections to this proposal
included a wildly creative hypothetical
of a 17-year-old service member shipping
off to war and potentially leaving
behind a pregnant girlfriend with no
access to Medical Services and while
that makes for a heart-wrenching
Hallmark movie it has absolutely no
basis in today's reality 17-year-olds
can only enlist with parental permission
the pregnancy exception is instead used
as a way to avoid rape charges a
marriage license can indeed cover up
sexual assault the United States
Department State Department labels
marriage before the age of 18 as a human
rights abuse just before New Hampshire
finally took a modum of action in
raising the marriage age from 13 for
girls and 14 for boys a 13-year-old girl
in new New
Market was married off to her abusive
17-year-old boyfriend having been
coerced by her parents they are now
divorced another objection is a
comparison of our own personal and
familial marriage experiences to today's
Norms social norms have changed
Americans are delaying or putting off
all together getting married for longer
than before according to data from the
US Census Bureau the median average age
for men to first get married has risen
to 30.2 years old in 2023 while for
women the figure is
28.4 again I refer refer you to the two
graphs provided in your
back my parents
dated and married young very young in
fact they married below the median and
average
ages and they celebrated almost 52 years
of
marriage they were married in
1968 five full years before the Equal
Credit Opportunity Act of
1974 that act finally granted women the
right to open their own Banking and
credit accounts outlawing discrimination
by sex in banking before that women
generally could not take out loans
without a male co-signer and lenders
often saddled female borrowers with
higher interest rates and larger down
payment requirements marriage at that
time was a financial best case scenario
the past 50 years have changed the
landscape of financial opportunity for
American women dramatically we need to
recognize the so socialization of women
and girls in the 1950s and 60s is so
very different than today I'm thrilled
to be joined here today by Advocates
from the national organization dedicated
to the eradication of child marriage in
America Unchained at last they will be
providing the committee with more
in-depth statistics and personal
experience as a visual for a moment
think about the Hall of
Representatives now fill that room
halfway and those are the children
married
off imagine facing each one of those
kids trapped in a marriage contract they
cannot exit and say there just aren't
enough of you to just ify my doing
anything to prevent this Hall from
filling up keep in mind none of those
children can gain sanctuary in a
domestic violence shelter if they need
it because they aren't old enough I want
to make it eminently clear that raising
the age of marriage does not in any way
shape or form pass judgment on anyone
else's marriagein marriage origin story
my parents included we can celebrate
those who followed a Teenage Love Affair
into a decades long marriage while
simultaneously acknowledging that
marriage is more than a love story it's
a contract too a contract that should be
entered into by consenting adults we are
the policy makers we can make this right
and set the legal age to enter into a
marriage contract at 18 cont contracts
are for adults let's fix this in New
Hampshire and I urge the committee to
recommend Senate Bill 359 as amended
questions any questions for the senator
I don't have an amendment uh the bill
itself was amended by the Senate at the
top where it says as amended by the
Senate yes yeah that's what I meant
that's that was a good away
yeah no more amendments I it's all done
senator seeing none thank you so much
all right thank you very much Mr chair
and honorable committee members and now
with all the pink cards all in favor of
the bill most of the cards said time
needed to speak 3 minutes that will now
be imposed on everyone speaking and by 3
minutes we mean 180 seconds
chair recognizes representative Timothy
Horan from straford District 10 to come
minutes Senator Al Shiller could you
fill out a pink
yeah you
did okay okay the clock starts now thank
thankk you so I'm rent Timothy Horan
from Stafford County District which is
just a town of town of Durham so I was
around in um 2009 when we passed the
marriage equality law which actually um
to take advantage of a same you know
same-sex marriage both parties had to be
18 and I think that was part of a
process of uh perhaps simplifying and
clarifying our understanding what
marriage is which is it's first and
foremost a contract between two people
and we used to think that one had to be
male and one was female and now it's
common place for people of the same
gender to marry but that's
uh that was something we recognized when
we uh created same gender marriage it's
something that should apply to uh when
they a male and the female are are
marrying I mean yes people who married
their lives are connected in all sorts
of ways and but there's lots of people
um who aren't married to each other who
are raising children lots of people have
married to other who are living together
lots of people who aren't married to
each other who are having sex and that
was true before 2009 it's even more true
now so I think
um so I think uh having a Uniform age of
18 to enter into the marriage contract
is uh is is just basically the way to go
so there it's just not an
equal it's just not a valid relationship
if either party or perhaps in some case
both are not able to enter into a
contract without parental uh parental
permission and of course the marriage
the divorce rate for people marry you
know child marriages is very high and
some cases uh the need to divorce
happens even
before um the party is is 18 and that
creates a very major problem since they
uh aren't able to initiate the divorce
proceedings um if they're under 18 so
that's um so I think uh I think just
build a simple common sense it just
clarifies what the evolution we've
already seen in merage law over the
years and it as I said it's a contract
between those two people and there's
lots of other stuff involved but it's
basically a commitment between those two
people so they should both be able uh
they should both be adults and able to
freely enter into the contract and I
don't know if the military thing is
going apparently it's not going to come
up during this hearing today which is
good but it it has come up on the floor
in the past and um so the military Ary
um the only the the military U you can
your child is eligible for military
benefits regardless of whether you're
married to the other parent there's only
issue is maybe you can't live on the
base if you're not married to 10 seconds
repres um the military thing which may
or may not come up during this debate C
apparently not during the hearing is non
is kind of nonsensical and if you feel
it's going to come up you probably
should have your researcher clarify it
cuz any questions for the
representative thanks representative
Panic
yeah I'm my understanding is once a 16
or 17y old enters into a marital
contract that they are considered by the
state an adult and that they could go to
see a lawyer and get the marriage
nullified or go through a divorce cuz
once they me enter into a marital
contract they considered adults so I
think it that's what I my understanding
was last year when this bill came well
that I would just say I'm not
necessarily the right person answered i'
I'm not a I'm not a lawyer I've also
actually never been legally married but
I have been in Partnership so I would
just say that's probably something um we
should have our excellent research team
clarify because I'm not sure if that's
actually true but even if you are sort
of Legally considered an adult it's
still more difficult if you're um under
18 and then there's problems you know
after the divorce is granted too so I
would I would just I would my first
impression is um I I disagree with what
you're saying but that's probably an
issue that uh we should have the
research to clarify if you think that's
an issue before we exec the bill and
certainly um it should be clarified
before we have the floor debate because
I know I know a lot of site issues have
come in in past floor debates and derail
previous attempts to pass this
legislation so that's about about all I
have to say although that was probably a
fairly lengthy answer but thank you any
further questions for the
representative seeing none thank you so
well
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Cassandra LEC I
represent straford 4 which is straford
and
barington in the past few years there
have been increased attention both
globally and nationally about the need
to end child marriage in the United
States bills have been introduced in
many states in attempt to end child
marriage since 2016 at least 25 states
have straightened their marriage age
laws but it is not enough we should be
stepping up and fully protecting them
from this human rights abuse you may ask
how is this how is child marriage a
violation of child's rights children
have the right to education to live
their life free from violence children
have the right to the best health care
possible the right to a clean and safe
place to live and develop in the best
way possible and they have the right to
information on how to be safe and
healthy survivors and those that help
these victim these childrens will and
have testified in multiple venues that
these rights are violated when the
children into marriages with adults the
US government has acknowledged that
child marriage is a human rights abuse
abolishing child marriage is a part of a
larger Global strategy to proot gender
equality and reduce poverty according to
the US Global strategy to empower
adolescent girls child early inforce
marriage arise from and often
perpetuates gender
inequality it is a human right abuse
that contributes to the economic
hardships and leads to underinvestment
in girls education and Healthcare
needs child early enforced marriage
undermines economic productivity
threatens sustainable growth and
development and fosters conditions that
enable or exacerbate violence and
insecurity including domestic
violence it produces devastating
repercussions for a girl's life
effectively ending her childhood early
marriage forces a girl into adulthood
and motherhood before she is physically
and mentally mature and before she
completes her education limiting her
future options depriving her of the
chance to reach her full potential and
preventing her from contributing fully
to her family and
Community let me further state that when
you open the door for child marriage it
is not only a child and child marriage
we are allowing we are allowing adults
to marry children we are allowing this
venue for human trafficking we are
allowing the corrosion of children there
is more at stake than teenage romance
and high school sweethearts marrying
child Brides face serious consequences
girls who marry at 18 or younger are at
30 are at 23% higher risk of heart
attacks you have 15 seconds left to wrap
it up okay and heart attack strokes and
diabetes and
cancer I've been fighting this since I
was 15 years old that is one year older
younger than my great-grandmothers and
my grandmother when they were married at
16 thank you representative will you
take some questions from your colleagues
absolutely questions from your
colleagues representative Panic do you
know how many uh child marriages
happened in New Hampshire um in the past
year or two um I used to I haven't um
gotten the full
update I'm sure I'm sure somebody will
be bringing that forward yeah zero and
the year before I think there was
two no somebody with the answers will be
bringing them for so let us not
questions representative
Perez uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question you know that I'm
being very vocal about this issue and
then I always support anything that has
to do with child marriage but my
question to do is um online two and
three uh no person below the age of 18
she'll be capable of Contracting a Val
marriage or marriage contract as such a
person should be null or void
um this is my only
concern and I know that I'm a Survivor
that you know I was I was married when I
was younger but my concern is that we
have people coming from other countries
that we have different different points
of view
and by no or avoiding something I'm I'm
just concerned that not every single
marriage ended into abuse relationship
or uh not work uh that's the only
concern that I do have so that would
fall under where we do we're state to
state type thing where we do recognize
that and if you get married like out of
state where they allow it or out of the
country where they do allow that then
we have to fall under Federal
jurisdiction I believe that's the Full
Faith and Credit Clause of the
Constitution so they wouldn't suddenly
be unmarried when they moved to New
Hampshire thank you representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question would you
agree that the number of marriages that
take place in New Hampshire uh child
marriages in New Hampshire is irrelevant
if you believe that child marriage is is
wrong yes I do believe that yeah good
point representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question and um I know I know you have
very good intentions in protecting young
women my question um kind of um stem
from some of the um testimony from the
representative before you um
we have a problem with teenage girls
cohabit with older men and with um their
teenage
boyfriend's
parents um you know living with with
them are you aware
of a young woman at the age of 16 or 17
or 15 who is in that situation would
they be able to go to a domestic abuse
shelter um I because they're underage
believe anybody under the age of 18 will
be turned away from all domestic abuse
shelters because they do not have a
legal guardian with them and most of
those
that um like if someone is trying to get
away from their spouse or whoever then
in these instances of child marriages
there are many victims who have gone to
domestic violence shelters and who have
been turned away or the police have been
escorted back to escorted them back to
their parents or their legal guardian
who happens to be their husband who then
further abuses them even more because
they try to get away from them followup
yeah I think probably that my question
isn't really germing into your bill or
Amendment but maybe we can work on
something like that in the future
together if we're reelected yeah thank
you any further questions for the
representative seeing none come on back
okay and I do have flash drives for
anybody that wants data on um child
marriage yep do they come with
instructions for old people I can show
you how to use thank
you just want to give chance to the
office of child advocate if you have any
information to that question about
turnaways you want to come up and answer
that question you don't have
to okay they wave off they look
embarrassed I'm sorry I should have
texted you okay all right the chair
Futures you asked for two minutes I'm
going to hold you to
free thank you for the extra
minute good afternoon oh it's still
morning five minutes good morning uh my
name is Emma I'm the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures new Futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that solves
problems through policy change um we are
here in strong support of Senate Bill
359 because it reduces adverse childhood
experiences or Aces um which have been
long uh linked to Serious long-term
health effects um not just in childhood
but throughout uh adulthood as well um
when children are engaged in uh a
marriage contract before they reach the
age of majority um typically these
stories are accompanied by um severe
trauma sexual emotional physical abuse
all of these highly traumatic events
contribute to lifelong consequences such
as um as you've heard heart disease um
mental health concerns substance use
disorder um children who have
experienced four or more Aces have
higher rates of being uh trafficked um
something as simple as back pain all of
these things can be mitigated by having
protective factors in place having
supportive uh adults outside of their
homes having
um uh access to services this bill is a
really important and critical step in
establishing one of those protective
factors protecting our young kids from
entering into a contract and having
these traumatic
experiences
I'll also note that this is part of a
national movement there have been um 11
states soon to be 12 states that have um
enacted legislation similar to this um
to end child marriage in their states
additionally um to answer rep panic's
question there have been 215 minors
married since 2000 between 20 2 and
20123 um since 2019 there have been nine
children who have been married 83% of
these were girls wed to adult men with
an average age difference of 4 years
older from the child who was married and
the 2018 legislation was certainly well-
intended but only protected about 4% of
the individuals that it needed to
protect the rest of those those um cases
are aged 17 and above every single life
is important even one child marriage is
too many
um we have done as a state so much to
invest in our system of care and invest
in the mental well-being of our children
I think this is an a a critical next
step in ensuring that we mitigate Aces
as much as possible happy to answer any
questions to the best of my
ability you have 10 seconds in the bank
for next time you come thank you any
questions representative Panic you're on
a rooll today yes I am thank you
chairman um out of those marriages that
occurred do you have the statistics on
how many ended up in divorce I don't
have those statistics off the top of my
you seeing nothing further thank you so
much thank you so much chair recognizes
Linn currya Stanley from the National
Association of Social Workers New
Hampshire chapter and thank you for the
good handwriting well thank you for
recognizing my good handwriting
um good afternoon uh members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
LIN cier Stanley I'm a social worker I
am the executive director of the
National Association of Social Workers
New Hampshire chapter and I live in
Penacook uh social workers have a number
of concerns uh about child marriage this
is this is not a maturity issue this is
a legal rights and responsibilities
issue um 30 40 50 year olds may not be
mature enough to get married um it is
about the legal rights and
responsibilities that you uh obtain Once
you turn
18 uh we are concerned about
parents prematurely relinquishing their
parental rights and handing it over to
another an 18-year-old a
45-year-old making them their
technically their legal guardian we are
concerned learned about um how child
marriage is used as a tool of child
traffickers somebody taking a
16-year-old across state lines for
nefarious purposes is committing a
felony somebody taking their wife across
state lines is just going to
Vermont we are also concerned about of
course about the mental health impacts
that child marriage can have we are
concerned for those children we are
concerned for the adults that they
become we're concerned for the social
workers who have to help those often
young women put the pieces back together
yes it is small
is it may not be meaningful to many but
it is absolutely meaningful to those who
it affects thank you very much and I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
might
have thank you thing none thank you for
your testimony handwriting in a minute
and 10
seconds to your credit
account Becca Powell from Unchained at
last and that intrigued me earlier when
term good afternoon my name is Becca
Powell and I'm here representing
Unchained at last uh the Survivor Le
nonprofit that's dedicated to ending
forc and child marriage in the United
States uh the 2018 legislation that
raised the marriage AG to 16 was very
well intentioned but it didn't go far
enough 96% of the minors who married in
New Hampshire before 2018 were aged 16
or 17 so the 2018 legislation only
protected 4% of the individuals it was
intended to protect but s SP 359 isn't
about creating a better system to enter
minors into marriage this bill will do
what 11 other US states have done and
set the marriage age at 18 no exceptions
uh because child marriage itself is
inherently dangerous as you heard this
has nothing to do with maturity minors
don't automatically wake up on their
18th birthday with some new wisdom or
ability to make good decisions what they
do wake up with is all the rights of
adulthood they didn't have even the day
before and that's so crucial especially
for a minor who is being forced to marry
before minor turns 18 they can't even
open the door and leave home to get away
if their parents are planning an
unwanted wedding for them uh minors who
run away from home are repeatedly
repeatedly can be deemed a child in need
of services and summoned to a court
hearing to determine further
disciplinary action in our experience
domestic violence shelters across the US
will routinely turn away unaccompanied
minors and youth shelters in general are
not a solution uh they typically only
limit the state of 21 days and their
main goal is to reunite that minor with
their parents uh additionally a minor
can easily retain an attorney because
contracts with miners are voidable and
they generally can't file a legal action
which just creates additional obstacles
for them and representative panic I want
to address a question you asked earlier
yes miners are automatically emancipated
upon marriage which does bring some
limited legal rights of adulthood
however these rights do arrive too late
to prevent a forced marriage that minor
would first have to undergo the trauma
of a forced marriage which in our
experience can typically mean being
pulled out of school raped on her
wedding night and forced into a life of
Domestic and Sexual servitude and you
can't undo this trauma and you can't
unrape a minor just by giving them some
limited rights of adulthood by
emancipating them afterwards also the
rights of emancipated minors are as I
said limited in our experience domestic
violent shelters will turn away even
emancipated minors and emancipated
minors often have trouble accessing the
rights that they do have imagine for
example how a landlord would feel uh
about renting an apartment to a 16 or
17-year-old uh and because of these
limitations globally child marriage is
recognized all child marriage is
recognized as being forced marriage
because minors just simply do not have
all of the rights of adulthood they need
to enter any contract let alone a
contract as serious as marriage and
because of this when girls have reached
out to Unchained who provides Direct
Services to those who are facing forced
marriages when girls under 18 have
reached out and asked for our help and
have learned of their limited legal
options we've unfortunately seen some
turn to self harm and even suicide
attempts uh so for all those reasons I
ask you to please do what the Senate did
and vote Yes on SP 359 and I'm happy to
answer any
questions representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um are you
familiar with our present
law here in New Hampshire yes uh 16 and
17 year olds can uh enter into marriage
with the consent of one parent and
judicial
review follow up um because I um do
think that um they do have certain
legal uh rights under that law
so as I said yes when they're married
they're automatically emancipated and
they do get some limited rights of
adulthood um but as I mentioned those
rights arrive too late to prevent a
forced marriage and you know that trauma
unfortunately can't be undone just by
giving them some of those limited rights
of adulthood um and additionally as I
mentioned those rights are only limited
and in our experience domestic violence
minors thank you for your testimony
thank you so much
chair recognizes Michelle is it
Foundation that's what it
says well I'm glad you could read my
handwriting I'm sure it was not only
that I'm intrigued tell me what aha
Foundation is sure aha Foundation is a
nonprofit no tell me what it means oh
it's our Founder's name excuse me Ian
her she was a survivor of forced
marriage and female genital mutilation
ah ah
okay three minutes thank you I am
Michelle hanash I am the director of
policy and women's programs at the AA
Foundation we are a nonprofit working to
end harmful practices like child
marriage we also receive those help
requests from individuals fleeing Force
marriages across the us including from
minors and it is because of these
heartbreaking stories that we are so
adamantly in support of s SP
359 and keeping the marriage age at 18
and eliminating the dangerous loopholes
that allow for children to be entered
into marriage and I believe in the past
it had been asked whether it would be a
good idea to add a military exception to
the marriage age that's not currently
the law and that's not proposed in s359
but I'd like to take just a few minutes
to explain why that would not be a good
idea so first to explain the common
misconception you do not need to be
married to list the mother of your baby
or anyone for that matter is the benefit
ICI of your death benefits and as you
heard children receive service members
benefits regardless of their marital
status and using other spousal benefits
that would not apply like health
insurance or housing to a non-married
partner are not a reason to keep
children entered into child marriage
using someone's Current financial
dependency as a as a justification for
child marriage will only keep them
further dependent and ryant on public
assistance government aid for a lifetime
we all believe that there are other
Solutions than entering children into
contractual sexual relationships in
order to receive housing or health care
we would say Medicaid not marriage and
sadly people sitting here today
testifying in support of this bill have
had to help children who were being
forced to marry service members and
those children receive protection as
much as any child being forced to marry
a civilian and you should know military
exceptions are not the norm only one
state Alaska has a military exception we
couldn't find any country even in a war
torn area like Afghanistan that actually
has a service member exception we have
support from service member advocacy
groups who are saying don't support
child marriage in our name a a letter of
support was submitted by protect our
Defenders saying just this we urge you
to listen to them and not cling to child
marriage a harmful practice that
prevents girls from having Liberty
economic freedom educational opport
unities we urge you to pass this
legislation as soon as possible thank
you so
much any
questions
aha representative I might as well just
get everybody upset with me we're not
upset with you well after I say this
we'll our lunch quickly thank you Mr
chairman
um my confusion here
is we're advocating for genital
reassignment surgeries for children
under 18 years old but you're not going
to allow them to be married under 18
years old I can't seem to line those two
different thought processes up I think
something like this needs to be left
alone it has to be a question
representative I mean how do you how do
you how do you justify that part and
then this part here where you're saying
you can't get married well reassign
genital surgeries but we won't allow you
to get married it just how do you as
square that away sure thank you for the
question as as people have mentioned
marriage is a contractual relationship
18 is the age to enter into
contracts setting the marriage age at 18
I should say keeping the marriage age at
18 and eliminating the loopless is
entirely consistent with the laws when
it comes to entering into a contract and
we should
um allow children to be abused because
of other issues that are being debated
when it comes to legislation ending
child marriage is entirely consistent
with the laws on childhood and on
contracts and
otherwise having loopholes in the law
completely makes a mockery of of so many
other laws when it comes to
children thank you any further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you so much Trey recognizes Mr
Dana
minutes good morning Mr
chair uh thank you uh just to address a
few things I heard earlier to begin with
a brief anecdote I once found myself
outside an abortion clinic speaking to a
young African-American gentleman very
upset uh that his uh European girlfriend
uh was not going to allow him to be a
father and so it seems uh uh this is off
topic please speak to the bill a brief
anecdote to uh frame the bill please all
right so the First Choice it seems is
death and I'm speaking to rep PR's
content uh comment and after facing
death we Face birth and then directly to
rep Perez's comment the next choice we
face is a gender assignment and whether
we are think we ought to be a boy or a
girl at a very young
age uh after that we Face the choice of
who we find
attractive after that we chase the
choice of
whether to consummate
that after that it
seems uh today's reality is we decide
whether that ought to be a marriage
death and um I find this a curious order
of
events and if you go to the most recent
Supreme Court
case uh
uh
2 2590 it says a third the US Supreme
Court says a third basis for protecting
the right to marry is that it safeguards
children and families and thus draws
meaning from related rights of
childbearing procreation and education
going back to pierce V Society of sis uh
sisters uh protecting religious
minorities so while many view marriage
is a legal contract if you look at line
15 here it says no magistrate or
minister of religion so solemnize any
marriage I submit there are many who
view it not as a legal contract but a
religious
um I'm not sure how this bill is written
doesn't run a foul of Berger fell both
in terms of due
process uh recognizing full faith and
credit and recognizing First Amendment
rights and granted it may be a very tiny
minority but I would just urge you to
consider this in the broader context of
all of these issues and at what ages all
of these sort of events ought to occur
thank
you any
questions seeing thank you for your
testimony um I do know that in Most
states the minister of religion is both
a minister of the sacrament and um a
legal representative of the state and I
do know that in those states where
sometimes those are in Conflict uh that
is a
discussion can the minister solize
matrimony for the church and not be a
representative of the state when those
two things Clash I'll just leave that as
an open issue okay thank you these are
just things I'm hoping you'll consider
as
you finally the chair recognizes uh
Freddy rice from Unchained at last and
you two have three
minutes Brooklyn I can talk very
quickly I'm Freddy ree I am here is
thank you I'm Unchained at last and I am
a a forc marriage Survivor so this is
very personal for me I'm also an
advocate through unchain at last we work
with survivors who are escaping forc
marriage and I'm an expert on this issue
my research and writing have been
published extensively I want to talk
about how the current law in
Massachusetts I'm sorry here in New
Hampshire allowing 16 and 17 year olds
to be entered into marriage actually
encourages legalizes and incentivizes
the trafficking of minors under the
guise of marriage the way it works is
the federal government does not specify
any minimum age for marriage and this is
a really dangerous and gaping and
shameful loophole in federal law that
allows and encourages the trafficking of
minors in the US and mostly it's girls
who are trafficked for the US
citizenship forced to marry adult men
overseas who get a visa and a path to
citizenship it also encourages and
legalizes the opposite men in the US can
bring in traffic sex traffic girls from
overseas minor girls under the guise of
marriage and it's perfectly legal so the
way it works is that USCIS and the state
department are allowed to approve the
petition of a spous for a spousal fiance
visa involving a minor only if the
marriage would be legal in the state
where the couple will reside and that
means that right now in New Hampshire
USCIS and the state department can
approve these petitions for minors as
young as 16 and 17 almost all of our
neighboring states in fact every single
one except for Maine has addressed this
problem by making the marriage age 18 no
exceptions because that way USCIS and
the state department cannot approve
these marriages but here in New
Hampshire our girls are not being
protected and this is not a small
problem by the way the US Senate
Homeland Security committee issued a
report in
2017 that showed that in the decade
leading up to that report there were
almost 9,000 petitions for a spousal
fiance visa involving a minor as young
as 13 that were approved by USCIS and
the younger party was a girl in 95% of
those cases let's catch up to the rest
of our uh to the rest of our neighbors
and uh 11 states across the US that have
solved this problem by making the
marriage age 8 no exceptions and
stopping the legal trafficking of
minors any
questions representative Nelson hi thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question I just I wanted to um just
get some clarification from you
um so you're saying that even if we have
uh per RSA uh age limitations and
residency limitations here in New
Hampshire already in law that the
Federal Government Can supersede
that so what I'm saying is the federal
government cannot supersede the minimum
age but it can follow the minimum age
and since the minimum age now is 16 that
means minors at age 16 or 17 can be
legally trafficked because USCIS can
approve that if we made the marriage age
18 the USCIS would not be able to
approve the uh spousal or fiance visas
for minors as young as 16 and 17 who are
being forced right now to uh marry adult
men overseas so they br traffic for
their citizenship can I please have a
follow follow um I believe in current
statute um both um parties have to be
New Hampshire residents my understanding
is that one party needs to be a New
Hampshire
resident
oh thank you any other
questions and Sher I wonder if I could
also address a question that was raised
before regarding emancipation so there
was discussion um representative panic I
hope that my colleague Becca explained
why the Emancipation that you're right
once you're married you're emancipated
unfortunately those rights arrive too
late to help somebody who is being
forced to marry something that we see
almost every day at unchain at last cuz
these girls reach out to us and we have
to say well nothing we can do until
you're married but beyond that actually
the automatic emancipation upon marriage
is extremely dangerous public policy
because once a minor is married and
emancipated they lose their parents
financial obligation to them and
typically before we emancipate a minor
here in New Hampshire under the new
emancipation statute we first make them
prove to a court that they are
self-sufficient in their personal and
financial affairs but nobody is looking
at that when we're emancipating minors
just because one of their parents
decided it was time for them to get
married because this can happen with
just one parents consent in most cases
then we're forcing these minors to
become financially dependent on their on
their spouse which is a known risk
factor for domestic violence but it also
creates another perverse incentive for a
parent to force their own child to marry
what we're seeing is that parents are
using this as a way to unilaterally
terminate the parental rights of the
other parent they can one parent can
marry off their 16 or 17-year-old
without even notifying the other parent
and then the minor is emancipated and
there goes that child support obligation
you never wanted to pay or the child
custody battle you want to get out of
and in fact what a case like this went
up to the Idaho Supreme Court where a
woman found out her aranged husband had
paid someone money to marry their
16-year-old daughter so he could get out
of their child custody battle and she
lost when she fought it out to the Idaho
Supreme Court Supreme Court said child
do you're saying nothing further thank
you for your testimony thank you please
vote Yes on S SP
359 now just a little straw poll we
don't have to exact this bill uh unless
we all want to so is there anybody who
thinks we should wait before we exact
up seeing no
thumbs that means we can go forward to
exec this bill so I Clos the hearing on
Senate Bill 359 and I now open the exec
motion I'm I'm ready to write I don't I
I will put all the letters down even
though I don't say them right yes yes
LEC got it I move ought to pass ought to
pass second that and
patrino
discussion I sensed on the part of a few
folks little bit of hesitancy and that's
okay that's why we have the discussion
representative deimon thank you Mr
chairman um I took the time to look it
up uh
on line 12 12 it says no magistrate or
minister of religion shall som solemnize
the marriage doesn't say anything about
justices of the peace who in this state
magistrates and a Justice of the Peace
can solemnize a
marriage so there's one issue that I
have with the bill could we look at just
that when one would think that no
justice of the peace May commit an act
against an RSA and if that person does
so that person will be subject to some
strictures and the ACT would be null and
void well doesn't say we can't do it
know what's your pleasure we can hold up
and of the argument you know we had
offline discussion that Justice is bound
by the RSA so the
RSA
yeah and if you think you're doing it I
think I'm a star for the Red Sox so it
yeah anyone else for discussion
representative
Bickford um the the issue of military
was brought up thank you Mr chair sorry
that was that was wrong this is
discussion I just call on you oh okay um
anyway military was brought up for an
issue and one of the things in the
military as I recall they pay more if
you have a wife or spouse I should say
and so they've created a benefit that
makes
this uh advantageous to get married at a
younger age a lot of people go on the
service at 18 19 years old and they I'm
going to say their girlfriend uh wants
to be with them or at least on base and
like I say they get money doing this I
know uh my my daughter was not underage
but that they get extra money for being
married you know that's not something I
really believe in because I believe in
equal pay for equal work but that's the
way the system is right now and
so I I'm hesitant to change because that
representative
of yeah so um I have researched this um
I've talked to many of my friends who
are military members I've talked to my
father who's military member there is no
room for a wife when it comes to basic
training when they enter into the
military there is no wife or spousal
housing they come with the trunk that
they are given and the clothes on their
back and then they are introduced into
basic training yes they do have housing
but they follow a chain of command like
the military does whoever is higher up
in the chain of command they get that
housing first and the military has
realized that marrying their they
realize that is an issue in
their that they're having with a lot of
their members um and I know I'm not sure
if there's been discussions of it I know
that I've talked to many military m
members who have said that that is an
issue that they're trying to face right
now of military members especially their
younger boys marrying off just to get
benefits When in fact there those
especially with the pregnant girls um
the girls that are pregnant um they have
found other there's better ways to go
about it then just mirroring off just
for benefits I think that's and also if
they find
that they are marrying just for the
benefits then they will be Court Marshal
and handle the way that the military
will handle it they don't just let
anybody get married just to get more
money they tend to have checks
imbalances in that military to
prevent members just to receive more pay
just from having a ring on their finger
rep Vice chairman
long thank you Mr chairman um
yeah this is this is these discussions
qualify why I believe that nobody should
be married under the age of 18 I mean
we're having a discussion
about a person going at the service that
may get another 20 bucks a week if he's
married so we're GNA you know so let's
incentivize that underage marriage so
somebody entering a service could get
extra 20 bucks or whatever they get I'm
sure it's not very much um
you know and didn't we have the
discussion on um you know other other
discussions on nothing to do with
marriage and the sanctity of it but just
an an advantage uh that's why I you know
I'm sticking with if you're not 18 years
married representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman so just to
kind of follow up on that it's called
so what happens in the military is you
get um a one-time bump when you add a
dependent it is not when you get married
it's when you add a dependent so that
dependent could be a spouse but it could
also be a a
child um
and it's interesting that we're having
this discussion and I'm I'm reminded of
um one of the representatives who spoke
who pointed out that we allow only
same-sex marriage starting at 18 so if
you have a gay military m at 17 who has
gotten permission from his parents to
join the military and they want to get
married now so that they can have that
spousal benefit they're not allowed to
they're only allowed to do it if it's
opposite sex apparently so to me for the
fraction of a percent of individuals who
this might apply to it's not a reason to
put in danger all of the other
individuals who are at risk of child
trafficking um and again the the bump is
a onetime thing when you added to
dependent um under their I forget what
it's called the it's their enrollment
system it's the acronym is deers but I
don't remember what all the the letters
stand for but basically it's adding your
dependence to their system and it's for
base housing basically and your cost of
living
increase
representative
Gord repres reprentative
Gabby
grman see at least it's the same first
letter the first know thank you Mr
worse thank you
um so this is my third term here and um
this has been discussed since my first
term with um representative Cassie L
bringing this forward for us um and I
absolutely support this
legislation um going round and round it
it my head you know we're putting kids
at risk we're putting young adults at
risk so whatever benefit May
outweigh whether it's a bump in pay or
what housing whatever it may may
be the effect on our
society when we have
traumatized individuals that have
experienced trauma
and
coercion that's going to affect us down
the road
um the other piece that's always come up
is this notion
that a young person under 18 can't
access help if they're in a domestic
violence
situation that has continuously come up
over and over being turned away from
from support and help because they're a
minor not being able to get a lawyer I
remember our first term it was I don't
think you could get a hotel
room as you know you couldn't get a
hotel room so you could get married um
so once again here we are and I'll be
voting um in support of raising the
you the chair wishes to thank Gabby M
Grossman for her
contribution and now the uh chair
recognizes representative Greg thank you
Mr chairman um I think you know there's
a lot of a lot of things when we look at
this bill and and between the house bill
that we had um this last year and then
this bill you know we're always looking
at you know a what type of kiddo in this
day and age is getting married that
early and we always go back to these
abuse things and and I think there's a
another thing that we're kind of missing
here and I know that the New Hampshire
way is we have our own little unique way
of doing things and that's that's
usually pretty great when we start to
see all the states around us um passing
these these marriage laws where we're
going to 18 what does that make us it
doesn't make us the outlier who needs to
play katchup what it makes us is it
makes us more attractive who is it
making us more attractive to it's making
us more attractive to these traffickers
yes we've only had so many marriages in
this last year but let's look at it we
have a n International problem of
trafficking especially with internet
especially with kids having their phones
and being able to get online and meet up
with people and stuff we will make
ourselves a very attractive state for
child traffickers to come so even though
we haven't seen that yet that's
something to keep in mind when we are
one of the only islands on this
particular matter so I will be voting
for this for a million different reasons
but that's an added one thank
you representative
Nelson um I'm feeling ambivalent right
now one way or the other but my concern
is that um is
this
we have such a larger problem with um
human trafficking sex trafficking of
minors and raising the age of marriage
to 18 is not going to solve that and
also in demestic violent situations of
minors who are
cohabitating so I am hoping that my
colleagues will join
me should we be reelected next time to
actually address the real problem that
you well my comment is uh when I was
young I visited my family in rural
Canada a little town called pearsonville
New
Brunswick and at 14 people were
responsible they did not have
adolescence you grew up quickly because
the cow had to be milked the absence of
Which is far more serious than you
didn't take out the trash every other
day and I noticed my cousins in Canada
were because of this much more mature
and so to get married at 15 and 16 was
not a maturity
problem well that's not the people I see
everywhere else I go even in rural
Canada as a result what might have been
okay there 60 years ago I do not believe
is okay here now and so I will be voting
for this
bill anyone else yes representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson um I
will admit that I voted against this
bill last year however um times have
changed in a very short period of time
and I'm very concerned that a same-sex
marriage is required to be 18 but we're
not providing those same protections to
the young women in our state um I will
this representative
Perez uh thank you Mr uh chair for
allowing me to speak um as you know uh
last year I was very vocal about this
bill um supporting RAC and data age 28
um have life experience with
um basically um I was only 15 years old
and my ex-husband he was 47 years
old um and someone who didn't know the
language uh someone who didn't know the
rights um I had 11 years
of trauma pain and um
struggles um and I don't wish anyone
because those scars um even though that
I feel like I heal um they're going to
be there for the rest of my life um and
I don't wish anyone not even my worst
enemy to go through what I have
experienced in 11 years of my life so uh
call the motion before us on Senate Bill
359 is ought to pass move by
representative LC second and by
representative Petrino would the clerk
please call the role chairman Pearson
yes Vice chairman long yes
Representative disimone no
representative
bfid yes representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes yes
representative
Panic yes representative Melvin yes
representative grman yes representative
LC yes representative Patrina will vote
Yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes motion carries
14-1 any objection representative D
Simon to consent no no objection it's on
consent and representative Lebec before
you leave today a nice little blurb for
the clerk please congratulations this
concludes the exec session on Senate
Bill 359 I wanted to go way into the
lunchar because I wanted a lot of people
who came here to see the disposition of
this
today now we're going to come back at
e
you
what
okay let's go Senate Bill 506 if you
watch dtown Abbey and remember Carson
this is a different Carson introducing
the
bill very much so good afternoon Mr
chairman and The Honorable members of
the House children and family law
committee for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14 which
comprises the town of Auburn Hudson and
londonairy and I have for your
consideration this afternoon Senate Bill
506 which seeks to align o other
statutes with the juvenile delinquency
statute RSA 169b which provides that a
delinquent includes anyone under 18
years of age
um there's only three points to this
bill this is a technical cleanup bill
when the state raised the age of a
juvenile for 17 to 18 a few spots in
statute were missed and this bill would
clean up those remaining references to
17 and I'm concluding my testimony Mr
chair and um wow the attorneys that are
here that requested the bill be filed
will be more than happy to answer your
questions any questions for the
senator seeing none thank you so much
thank you Mr chairman and the chair
recognizes I'm going to say attorney
Stephen
Andre you know they're trying to get me
to go to law school I'm getting law
books for Christmas now so well I I was
going to say you had mentioned the Rules
of Evidence book yeah I read it four
times with the footnotes I think that
book costs over
$200 the little tiny skinny one yeah
anyway the chief gave me a copy and I
know it's going to be on the test so I
read four times it really is um my name
is stepen Andress I'm an assistant
County Attorney at the marac county
attorney's office I've been a prosecutor
for over 20 years now um just to not
reiterate what Senator Carson said but
essentially this bill um in 2017 the age
for entry into the criminal justice
system was raised from 17 to 18 years
old and there were a number of statutes
that were sort of lagging behind that
didn't get changed this goes back looks
at those statutes and changes the age to
18 so that everything is aligned now and
questions I was going to say there was
also a handout that the
handout around that has everyone who
supports it written in it wow thank you
any
much no other pink
cards so therefore I conclude the
hearing on Senate Bill 506
FN and what do you think yeah y yeah the
last time I testified and said this is a
housekeeping thing two hours later it
was turned into something totally
different it was a significant
Improvement thank you Lucy
Weber but I don't use those words
anymore but this I think
qualifies
all right then I will open the executive
session on Senate Bill 506 and who would
like to make a motion this gives you the
honor of writing the blur of
Representative
ball you cannot withdraw that so who can
second oh it's Greg yeah representative
discussion
midd Molita M Malia
wow yeah
discussion I've learned uh
representative Grossman's middle name
during this break anything
else all right we have a motion before
us on Senate Bill 506 FN the motion is
pass by representative Ball seconded by
representative Greg would the clerk
role chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman
long yes representative diamon is not
present at the moment representative
bfid yes representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative Melvin yes
representative grman yes representative
L is not president representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Raymond yes motion
carries 13 to zero any objection to
consent seeing none on to consent it
goes this concludes the exec session on
Senate Bill 506 and now open the hearing
on Senate Bill
498 uh relative to
dcy F and in today's uh exciting episode
the part of um
what you're not coming back till
1:30 three more minutes we have three
clock but it's Tuesday not Wednesday
right oh thank you
oh she came to our Halloween day as
Wednesday
Adams she she rocked it it was really
good and she was very polite and didn't
It is Uncle fer Uncle Fester yes yes I
can
uhhuh
now you got
[Laughter]
it thank you that it
appreciate yeah folks if you're
interested in going on either or both of
those uh committees we put together this
morning uh just send me a note thank you
representative
Perez
that by the way is The Final
Countdown I played that before wedding
once they had been engaged for like
eight years and I was the organist that
wedding and they were goofballs both of
them and I figured what the heck and so
I did my nice 20 minute concert and they
were late and when the bride finally
came around the corner I gave a rousing
chorus of The Final Countdown and they
like that much more than um Vagner which
was The Wedding March yeah okay do I
have a who is do I have a card introduc
this Miss
Dyer may
I open the hearing on Senate Bill 498 FN
relative to the Department of Health
Human Services Division for children
youth and families in today's exciting
episode the part of Senator Bradley is
being played by the chair so I am
introducing this bill and I have some
Allstar cast of people ready to speak to
it and some written doc so the chair
larabe good afternoon chairman Pearson
and members of the children and family
law committee my name is Susan laraby I
am general counsel and chief of
legislative affairs for DCF good
afternoon uh this um is a d a DH HS uh
requested Bill and I'm here to provide
information for you and to go over the
bill Senate Bill
498 basically Senate Bill 498 uh in the
first section uh aligns and adds
language the Juvenile Justice
delinquency section of
169b which is in on page one sections
one through 4 which would be lines 1
through 30 as well as 169 D which is
children in need of services which
begins on page two and that's line 15
continuing onto page three through line
13 basically what the the added language
aligns with the child protection act of
169c uh pertaining to the placement
options uh for children that is
consistent with federal law the family
first Prevention Services Act of
2017 which allows for not just relative
caregivers but Kinship Caregivers to uh
be a placement option for children not
just with uh CPA with the child
protection act but for children involved
with the juvenile justice system in both
the delinquency and shins act and that
language of adding kinship would be
aligning with that with both federal and
state law as well as adding the
placement options of certified
residential or psychiatric placements
that is also part of the children
protection
act uh secondly on page two uh section
five which is lines 1 through 14 will be
amending the reporting dates of the
Youth Detention Center logs uh those
reports go to the department um of
Health and Human Services uh by anually
and the way it's stated in the statute
now the dates of reporting are uh
January 1st and July 1st we request that
the bill be amended as the language
dates in Senate Bill 498 to align itself
with the federal reporting dates of the
Juvenile Justice delinquency prevention
act which would change the dates uh
reporting to October 1st and April 1st
and lastly uh this bill on page three
which is uh section 10 of the bill uh
lines 14 through 19 this bill would
repeal the perspective repeal of the
section uh known as the rebuttable
presumption of harm that went into
effect in
2021 with House Bill 1162 that had a
sunset provision of July 1st of this
year of 2024 so this bill would be
repealing the repeal of that sunset
provision we have asked for that because
we find that the rebuttable presumption
of harm is a very important evidentiary
tool it is trauma informed with all that
we know about Early Childhood adverse
effects it does not change the
definition of neglect that's why it's an
evidentiary tool under 169
C12 the definition of neglect Remains
the Same it's a two-prong definition in
which a child is a neglected child is a
who is without proper care necessary for
the child's physical mental or emotional
well-being and then that second prong is
that when it is established that a child
has suffered serious impairment or is
likely to suffer serious impairment I
know it's it's a mouthful and there's
many elements involved with uh what
factors uh the court is to consider when
looking at serious
impairments and the Supreme Court has
has simplified it to be harm harm to a
child or potential harm to a child and
that's the hard part sometimes in court
because that's not in line with what we
know about Early Childhood adverse
effects and that harm occurred but it
may not immediately manifest itself it
may not be readily a parent to a child
who has been exposed to certain
situation and experiences in their home
and
therefore that would prevent sometimes
the state from acting from
intervening or delay intervention
waiting for that harm to manifest itself
and that's not in line what what we all
as a society know about Early Childhood
adverse effects and therefore four years
ago as my understand that the
legislature heard testimony from many
entities including um a review of the
federal review of cases that were not uh
acted upon and saw that consistently
those were the ones that were considered
to be exposure cases when children were
exposed to certain conditions in the
home and those conditions put them at
risk of serious impairment so therefore
House Bill 1162 which is a lot of great
things for child welfare it finally
defined psychological melt treatment it
finally included a stepparent as a
parent of a child and it included four
rebuttable presumptions of harm in which
the court may make a finding that a
child has been harmed a rebuttable
presumption that this child has been
harmed unless and until proven otherwise
to certain exposure cases and that is
when a child is exposed to substance
misuse in the home that is adversely
affecting the care of the child when a
child is exposed to driving while
intoxicated by being in the car with a
parent who is driving while impaired
three when a child is exposed to
physical violence in the home by the
parent the parent is either physically
uh violent towards another child in the
home or another adult in the home and
that child is exposed to that and lastly
when a child is exposed to psychological
melt treatment either they themselves
are the victim of psychological melt
treatment or they are exposed to psych
psychological melt treatment in the home
to another adult or another child in the
home and that is a very important
evidentiary tool that we hope with the
passage of this bill uh that you pass
this bill to repeal the repeal of that
those rebuttable presumptions of
harm and I will be happy to answer any
questions about the bill under those
four three of them are very discreet
situations but I question about
psychological maltreatment how broadly
could that be for example the child
really wants something and the parent
parents for whatever reason do not
believe that the child should have that
uh we're talking major things um would
that be considered psychological
maltreatment and the child could say I
wanted to have tattoos and my parents
forbad me and because of that I am
suffering uh to me psychological
maltreatment could be could be runaway
if I may with House Bill 1162 the
definition of psychological melt
treatment was added to the definition
section of 169 C3 and if you could give
me a moment I believe I did bring the
actual statute with me well if you
perfect
I can go so before I joined DCF as a as
a uh general counsel I worked for UNH
and I was um a trainer and after 1162
was passed it included the provision
that all DCF and other stakeholders be
trained on House Bill 1162 and I was
actually a trainer of that so I will
refer to my PRI previous notes on the
trainings that were some years ago so
definition
for
it defines psycle the law the statute of
1162 added to the definition of
psychological Mel treatment and was
added into the law of pervasive and
emotionally abusive Behavior which shall
include but not be limited to patterns
of threatening berating or demeaning
Behavior so it's a course of conduct of
behavior that is threatening berating or
demeaning parents being parents and
saying no you cannot do that would not
fall under any of those unless the
language used and so it becomes a
berating language or physical
threatening language correct because as
we know uh you know emotional abuse and
words have sometimes a lot more effects
on a child than oh sure but sometimes
saying no a child can perceive that
course of course and that's why I think
um you all if anyone was present during
the house bill 1162 took all that in
consideration and talked about pervasive
and emotionally abusive Behavior yeah I
was a co-sponsor to that so I just want
to make sure I didn't uh you know open
up something representative D
Simon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so when I
raised my children I had a sign on the
refrigerator that I replaced frequently
because I had to get the Jelly stains
off and it said um Sticks and Stones can
break your bones but where can break
your
heart and I always said to the children
be careful how you speak to somebody so
I found
it diff difficult for myself when I
reported somebody for calling their
child an effing moronic
idiot and when I reported it as abuse I
was told sorry so it seems like this
bill am I correct that this bill will
make a corrective action in in that
aspect when you're constantly verbally
berating and telling a child that they
are not what they what you are telling
them they
are exactly because it's patterns of
threatening berading or demeaning
Behavior so in the court of law that' be
very hard to prove that a child has been
harmed without this rebuttable
harm time thank you representative
Nelson thank thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my call do you have
um why um what was the sorry I'm What
would I'm just like wondering it's
baffling what was the reason for uh the
repeal of
that that's a good question I don't know
actually the origin of why it has sunset
provision in it um I know that these
rebuttable presumption of harms the four
of them replace the opioid um rebuttable
presumption that had a sunset so I don't
know if that's why it was replacing
another provision that did Sunset but
other than that I would be only
guessing
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um I actually wanted to just go
back to um the first and second parts of
the bills can you just um explain
fictive Ken and what that legal
definition is for us just because it's
something new since I worked at DCF
years
ago I can uh fictive kin is defined in
17025 Roman numeral 8 in which kin means
a child means a child or children who
for which there is a connection or
history between a child or their parents
and another responsible adult including
but not in not limited to a relative or
related adult so it's someone known to
the child it can be a relative but it
doesn't have to be a relative it can be
a coach it can be a teacher it can be a
great
right the yes representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson thank
you for your time and coming to answer
our questions
um there's something about this that's
just not sitting right with me
um at the current moment because you're
saying threatening berating and
demeaning which is which are all very
subjective which means we're placing our
values on another family without even
the evidence that there is harm being
done I know that I understand that over
the long run you know children we all
have stories about what our parents
might have done to us um but I'm
concerned and I'm just wondering how
does this
fit um when you talk about psychologic
iCal
maltreatment where does parents that
have diagnosed mental illness of by
maybe borderline personality or bipolar
disorder is this going to
unfairly impact them because that's how
they could tend to treat their children
with a lot of threatening behavior or
Bering or um especially with a B one
minute they're they're happy go-lucky
parents and the next minute they're
screaming at their children so I'm just
wondering how is this going to affect
our community that is diagnosed and is
that going to stop people from getting
from getting help for their um mental
health
issues thank you for the question well
first of all it's twofold the rebuttable
presumption of harm is applying
psychological Mel treatment that
definition is is defined in the
definition section of 169 C3 and that is
not part of the repeal the repeal is the
rebuttable presumption of harm and again
it's a rebuttable presumption it's not
an irrebuttable presumption of harm so
if there's testimony that the parent was
repeatedly um calling a child a a
derogatory name in terms of calling them
uh obese and what that means to be
calling them obese and did certain
actions because they called them obese
or uh did other forms of emotional abuse
that's a rebuttable presumption it's not
irrebuttable
until unless proven otherwise it just
makes it easier to prove harm but it's
not saying it is harm in and of
itself followup follow
up so just to to make sure I'm getting
this clear so I understand that it's a
rebuttable but it's also presenting an
opportunity for parents to go after each
other in making claims against the other
parent for what they would perceive as
mistreatment or um I'm just I guess I'm
I'm worried about the subjectiveness of
it of especially when it's something
that you're not seeing it's just
something maybe I wouldn't particularly
raise my children doing it one way so
I'm I'm trying to understand and square
this whole thing is how do
we one is how do you prove it but also
how do you disprove an
allegation well I think you have to also
start the foundation of that all
evidence in court has to be material
reliable and found to be credible for it
to be found to even apply the rebble
presumption of harm so typically say for
instance if there's a child who goes to
the Child Advocacy Center and has a
forensic interview in which the child
describes acts of the parent that is
emotionally abusive and berading and
that is evidence that's material
evidence it's reliable evidence it's
credible evidence that the state would
put into evidence during an abuse and
neglect action for psychological
maltreatment and that evidence is
weighed by the judge so doesn't doesn't
shange like I said before it doesn't
first it doesn't change the um evidence
of putting in reliable credible evidence
it's just that once that evidence is
ruled to be reliable and
credible uh admissible evidence then the
judge weighs that with the evidentiary
tool of a rebuttable presumption of harm
the chair welcomes Attorney John
Williams to where he is now seated and
and thank you very much chairman uh for
the record my name is John Williams I'm
the legislative director for Health
Human Services and just here to
compliment the testimony that's being
provided to you very astute uh testimony
um from attorney larby uh I actually was
involved with the underlying Bill
working with many of you on the
committee that dealt with the rebuttable
presumption around harm what I wanted to
clarify particularly for you represent
Paul that is actually currently in law
today and the reason the sunset
provision was placed into the bill was
primarily at the request of the
pediatricians in from Dartmouth and
other areas because they were concerned
about the perhaps chilling effect that
would have in terms of reporting uh in
cases where a parent might have a
subance a subance use um matter and so
we have worked with a very collaborat
you heard from attorney larby about the
training that we've done for the
interpretation to making sure that we're
very sensitive because we want people to
address their subance use issues and
also we want to make sure that kids are
safe and I think we've done a really
good job balancing the the um whole
perspective of the current law now the
sunset was put in here specifically for
this to be Road tested and I'm not
saying because you don't hear clamors of
hundreds of people behind us that that
is evidence because that's kind of lack
of evidence uh but it is an occasion
where this has been rot tested and gone
through the process and that's why we're
here today to request this committee to
remove the sunset provision again the
issues that you're you're discussing are
in current law there not this is nothing
new that this bill is trying to do it's
just eliminating the sunset provision in
the law because it is working and it is
protecting kids and if it isn't working
in the future you will certainly have
folks coming before you seeking other
changes of law but we're not trying to
change at all and I'll repeat we're not
trying to change at all the current
provisions of the law as it relates to
the um rebuttable uh proof of harm so
attorney lar
anything I have a question and um some
of you may remember house bill
1573 which was about outplacement of
children who needed to be placed
somewhere and there
was there were hours upon hours upon
hours of work that went into that by the
office of the child advocate and
Department of Health and Human Services
and one poor legislator who really
wonders um please tell me that this
498 is in is in a different place it is
not um dealing with 1573 or it's Senate
cousin I think it's 417 this is uh
something different
correct thank you yeah and and I don't
say the same word uh chairman that you
also say about certain types of bills
and I probably met a couple of your
folks returning from lunch that I did
this uh this truly is one of those bills
that were coming back again the fredkin
very helpful pieces around Family First
putting that into legislation changing a
the date for reporting for detention
from January 1st to October uh are the
periods that we had under the federal
and then finally just seeking not any
change to current law as it relates to
rebuttal Pro of harm but just uh
addressing the sunset provision if we do
if you do nothing here today what will
end up happening is that it is scheduled
a sunset on June 30th of of this year
and so that's are here very thoughtfully
to saying it's working it's been Road
tested and if there's any other changes
needed people will come to you our only
goal here is to address the sunset
further thank you counselor and thank
you counselor thank you all thank you
this now ends the hearing on Senate Bill
498 and uh we're done we're done where
was the
card
that's not the
point the question is we usually have
the cards do you have something you want
to
softy J recognizes Vice chair Erica Leon
from Health and Human Service elderly
Affairs committee uh thank you Mr
chairman I apologize for not passing
that up Sumer I remember you calling
many last calls for cards in the I'm
sorry for being
grumpy um I I'm representative Erica
Leon I represent the town of dairy um I
come to speak to you about my concern
about um one particular phrase that is
included in here fictive kin um my
concern around that is as I was looking
through the statutes I know it was
referenced but I did not find it in our
existing statutes and I also um am just
quite concerned
about the possibility of placing
children with somebody who may not may
have an inappropriate relationship with
them and maybe in a position of
authority um my mother was a public
school teacher and um the only way that
they found out that there was a teacher
who had Decades of inappropriate
relationships with children was after
the teacher's lounge was vandalized in a
horrific way because the same thing had
happened to one Boy's brother that had
happened to him
until that day that teacher was well-
loved and well respected but they found
out that there had been a pattern of
abuse over decades um my concern is
simply around the fictive kin I
recognize the need to make sure that
there are people who are important to a
child who are involved when I first
heard about this I asked what's fic of
King kin oh that must be Uncle Mike my
husband's best friend from growing up
who is the one who will be raising our
children should something happen to us
um and we have that in documentation I
know not everybody else does but my
caution here is that there are people
who are involved in children's lives
there's one from my town who had been um
an assistant at a school and she has
another parole hearing coming up she had
an inappropriate relationship with one
of the students what if he had been
placed in that house um the horrors that
had happened there would have been even
worse so I just some caution on
expanding the ease of placement in
fictive kin because you know I i' say
probably
99,999 out of 10,000 people who would be
in that situation are good but we need
to be sure that that balance of power
and the potential for an inappropriate
relationship with somebody in a position
of power isn't something that moves a
child from the frying pan Into the
Fire any questions for vice chair Leon
representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um Do You
Believe that there are also um people
who are relatives and
Guardians um who also are abusers and
it's already inlaw that they would
be able to be responsible for this
child's care yes and that was one of the
challenges and tragedies that faces
especially this committee dealing with
those difficulties because you can't you
need to treat everybody fairly and
sometimes there's bad people that are
able to disguise how they act act um and
it's the challenge if this was easy all
these kids would be safe um and I
commend you guys for everything you do
in order to protect children followup
um with that being said I think it's
logical that um we would have to treat
everybody in in uh this presly in
statute and also fictive kin in the same
way um in order to uh vet them equally
because we would have to um view all of
them as a you know potentially either
very good equally or harmfully
potentially um so how would you like
what what would be the difference in
vetting those two types of people well
thank you for that question um I I
recognize the vetting process is
challenging it's something that actually
is probably worth some evaluation and to
see what that vetting process is and to
make sure that in certain situations
it's not fast-tracked just because of a
good feeling about somebody um that's
something that I promise I'll look into
and see if there's something that can be
done in terms of that however the more
that we open this up to to additional
people the more that the the more
opportunities for problems there are yet
I also understand we don't want to be
putting children into homes we don't
want to be shipping them out of state we
don't want to be putting them somewhere
else but we need to ignore a knowledge
the fact that there can be um
inappropriate
relationships representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman my question is
actually for you Mr chairman can we ask
um DCF what or the representatives from
DHHS what the vetting process is for
placement with um people who aren't
certified foster homes or certified
placement representative I was just
about to do that oh thank you so thank
you for seconding that because I I think
the Representative makes a good
point thank you if you're done with me
I'll step away from here thank you for
hearing me Cher Le on nothing thank you
thank you now how about representative
Raymond's
question you're it guys you too you're
you represent all 4800 DC uh DHHS
employees well thank you um yeah so back
in 2022 k ship Care Homes were added to
the definition of foster care um uh
facilities uh kinship Care Home Means A
type of foster home in which an
individual or individuals are licensed
to provide care exclusively to Kin and
then like I said before kin is defined
as I read that definition earlier uh
there shall be a maximum of six children
in the home and children uh and children
receive for child care who are related
to the residents um those six other
people uh we are currently in a contract
with um an organization called a a
second chance they are the ones that are
licensing uh these kinship Care Homes um
so once they are licensed they are able
to receive foster care payments because
that was the hurdle that many uh
relatives and fictive kin were being
vetted but were unable to receive foster
care payments and maintenance for the
care of these children so based on the
changes to the statute in
2022 these kin homes will be are LIC are
being licensed and will continue to be
licensed and during that licensing
process there's obviously a an
application of vetting um a home study
um a study uh background checks and and
all that goes into um making sure that
the child is placed in a safe and
appropriate home that is with someone
they
know follow up thank you Mr chairman so
in so what happens when there's an
emergency or even in in this case where
a delinquency has happened and a child
needs
placement do they have to go to a group
home while the you know the you know
Uncle Mike or whomever is being vetted
through the vetting process or can they
go there like on a conditional basis
while the my understanding again my
understanding is I'm not the subject
matter expert at this but this is my
understanding working on the uh
licensing process with kinship Care
Homes is that there certain things that
are called day one non-negotiables that
have to be done that day one to in order
to place um uh child with the uncle and
that uncle has to have a background
check which would require the uh cpsw to
call the local PDS to come in observe
the home do a walkth through of the home
and answer ask and be answered uh
certain non-negotiable questions
regarding safety of that child and then
after that the more for formal vetting
goes in terms of the FBI fingerprinting
the background checks the central sexual
um I'm sorry the central registry uh for
abuse and neglect the sex offender
registry uh and other um processes of
individual thank you okay oh one more
pink
card uh chair recognizes The Honorable
Betty
gay an
America
representative this isn't written down
Betty gay from Salem and I'm going to uh
try to IM give a example of what
representative Nelson referred to I had
never heard of fictive kin until January
when a person who I now I can't name
them because it does involve a child but
a person that you've heard many times so
you'd have respect for had a child
15-year-old knock on her door and ask if
she could have a drink of water she had
been walking
from she'd been walking a long time
turns out everybody at school and the
police knew this child's
situation the person abusing her was her
aunts
husband so she could have been there but
thank goodness for fictive kin this
person who home she just decided to walk
up to cuz it looked like a place people
came to they had a sign out front
um this child the school knew the
situation and the police actually had
her real aunt say to them that very day
I don't want her
um and because it just like it was
pre-ordained It was supposed to happen
this child is now under their care it
was established
immediately because of the fictive kin a
a
permission I'm not sure what word to use
but because it is
allowed she this child could once again
go into a home and be cared for while
they were doing all the steps necessary
because if they had waited for the um
for them to complete the foster care
that would have taken a few months
meanwhile this child needed shelter
immediately and so the story that's how
I found out about it because I was
called would you be a reference you know
a personal reference for the the uh new
fictive
parents so I thought but I had to say
this because as representative Nelson
pointed
out you don't want to send a child
anywhere where they're not going to be
cared for safely but you can't just
assume that because they are relatives
that it's any safer than someone that
you're vetting and have a relationship
with so I certainly support continuing
continuing the fictive relationship
qualifying people to be uh caretaker
Akers of children who need a safe home
any questions for the retired
representative thank you thank you you
know we all knew what this was it was
that nice person down the road that was
gosh he's more close to me than my
biological aunt and uncle are we just
didn't know what the term is so I think
we've all had um knowledge of fictive
except for the title well what do you
think folks ready to go ahead on this
one too all right yes representative
uh um Raymond was that hand no I meant
it to be a thumbs up oh that was more
than one thumb
okay all right who would like to move
OTP and write the blurb oh this ends the
hearing on S SP 498 and this opens the
exact session on it as well who would
line I'll I'll make the motion I can
have the sheet and the motion is uh the
motion is OTP on 498 please thank you
and who is that representative deimon
okay and let's roll on this one because
she's got to leave yep 498 relative to
dcyf mooved by representative Raymond
second by representative D Simone clerk
please call the
role jamman Pearson yes Vice chairman
long yes representative disimon yes
representative
Bickford not here at the moment
Nelson Nelson Nelson uh representative
McMahon yes representative ball
representative Panic yes representative
Melvin yes representative
grman yes representative LC is not
present representative Patrina will vote
Yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes that would be 13 to zero
zero
consent yes good thank you this ends the
uh exec session on S SP 498 it also ends
our day and once again on the first two
bills we saw that were establishing
committees if you would like to be on
one or both of them please either email
accordingly and there we
are hey on the second chance do they vet
household members also do they vet
household
members do they do they vet on Second
Chance do they vet household members
also okay
get and even
if